REVIEW OVERSIGHT HEARING OF THE
SENATE BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
AND THE ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE WILL COME
TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING. IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVE IN
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT. PUBLIC LEGISLATING THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING. HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
TODAY WE HAVE CENTER ARCH
ALETTA AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
ARAMBULA BLOOM EGGMAN FONG AND
GRAYSON. PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
IN THE SENATE CHAMBERS WITH ME
ARE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HELLO CHAIR
OF THE ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. AND I
HOPE AND EXPECT SOON TO BE
JOINED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KING. AND QUITE POSSIBLY
SENATOR PAT. WE ALSO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE BOARD
OF PHARMACY THE PODIA ETTRICK
MEDICAL BOARD AND THE BOARD AT
THE APRIL SCIENCES WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONE OR COMPUTER THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. PASSAGE
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU'D LIKE TO FIND MUTE. PLEASE
SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING. R. I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON YOU WHEN
YOU ARE DONE. ONCE RECOGNIZED
TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU
CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN.
STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU'RE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
TO ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS%
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AS YOU
CAN SEE NOW AND I'M GOING TO
ANNOUNCE IT. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR THAT'S EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE. SIX
THREE SIX FOUR IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS. FOUR SEVEN SIX. EIGHT
FOUR TWO NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW HE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE. AND ARE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR TODAY'S
HEARING PUBLIC COMMENT MAY BE
PROVIDED FOR A PARTICULAR
PROGRAM AFTER THE PROGRAM HAS
PROVIDED OPENING REMARKS IN
UPON THE CONCLUSIONS. OF
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS NEEDED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARING IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW AT USE
OF ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT TO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES SO THEY CAN BE HEARD.
TODAY'S HEARING IS THE FIRST IN
A SERIES OF RESCHEDULED SUNSET
REVIEW OVERSIGHT HEARINGS FROM
THE- THOSE THAT WERE POSTPONED
EARLIER THIS YEAR TO THE TO THE
CALVET NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THESE
HEARINGS ALLOW FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF REGULATORY
PROGRAMS. AND TO DETERMINE
WHETHER CHANGES IN THE LAW. FOR
THEIR OPERATIONS ARE FUNCTIONS
ARE NECESSARY. WE WILL BE
REVIEWING SPECIFIC ISSUES
REGARDING THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY. THE PODIA ETTRICK
MEDICAL BOARD AND THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES TODAY. TO
ASSIST IN THE REVIEW AND
EVALUATION OF EACH AGENCY
COMMITTEE STAFF PREPARED
BACKGROUND PAPERS WHICH
IDENTIFY ISSUES AND MAKE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR EACH
PROGRAM. THESE PAPERS HAVE BEEN
POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AND MADE AVAILABLE TO
INTERESTED PARTIES. EACH
PROGRAM WILL PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THEIR FUNCTIONS
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WILL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO RAISE
ANY OTHER ISSUE OR QUESTIONS.
WHICH THEY MAY HAVE. WE WILL
ALSO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY HERE
FROM CONSUMER GROUPS
PROFESSIONAL ORGANIZATIONS AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC FOR EACH
PORTION OF TODAY'S HEARING. I
WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME AND
INVITE ASSEMBLY MEMBER EVAN LOW
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. TO
PROVIDE ANY OPENING REMARKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR
GLACIER ASSEMBLY WHEN I WANT TO
THANK. YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF AS
WELL FOR HELPING TO PARTNER
WITH OUR RESPECTIVE COUNTERPART
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE EXTENSIVE AND
EXHAUSTIVE STAKEHOLDER INPUT TO
ENSURE FOR THE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WITH RESPECT TO
THE OVERSIGHT. AND THE
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
AND THE BOARD THAT EXIST IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE OF THE
ONGOING COVERT HEALTH CRISIS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THESE HEARINGS TO CARRY OUT THE
IMPORTANT OVERSIGHT.
COLLECTIVELY I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY BMP COMMITTEE WHO HAVE
JOINED US HERE AS WELL. AND TO
THE- THROUGH YOUR INDULGENCE
ALLOW THEM ALSO TO PROVIDE ANY
PARTICULAR INPUT AND SHOULD YOU
SEE FIT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU CHAIR LOW IT'S GREAT
TO PARTNER WITH YOU AGAIN IN
WANT TO. I EXTEND MY THANKS TO
YOUR STAFF FOR THE GREAT WORK
THAT THEY DID IN PREPARING THE
BACKGROUND HEARINGS THE
WITNESSES AND ALL THE
PREPARATIONS FOR TODAY'S
HEARING THANK YOU TO YOU AND
YOUR WONDERFUL STAFF. BEFORE WE
BEGIN WITH OUR SPEAKERS I'D
LIKE TO INVITE THOSE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO WISH TO
PARTICIPATE. TO CALL IN NOW YOU
CAN DIAL THIS TOLL FREE NUMBER.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND WHEN
PROMPTED PLEASE USE THE ACCESS
CODE. FOUR SEVEN SIX EIGHT FOUR
TWO NINE. BEFORE I BEGIN WITH
OUR FIRST THAT. PATTULLO WANTED
JUST BE SURE OF ANY CENTERS ARE
SELLING MEMBERS IN THE ROOM
HAVE ANY COMMENTS THEY WISH TO
MAKE I'M GONNA LOOK CHECK THE
MONITOR. I DON'T SEE ANY HANDS
UP SO WE WILL NOW BEGIN WE'LL
HEAR FROM THE BOARD OF PHARMACY
JOINING US TODAY IS A GREAT
LIFT THE WHO IS THE BOARD
PRESIDENT AND SODA GRIN THE
BOARD'S EXECUTIVE OFFICER THEY
SHOULD BE ON THE LINE OF LIKE
TO WELCOME CLOSER LISTER LIPPY
AND MISS SUTTER GRIN TO OUR
HEARING. AND WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE THEM TO PRESENT THEIR
OPENING REMARKS. GOOD MORNING
GOOD MORNING. MORNING
CHAIRPERSON GLAZER CHAIRPERSON
LONG COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
STAFF. MY NAME IS GREG WILL BE
AT THE PRIVILEGE OF SERVING AS
THE PART OF TRAVESTY PRESIDENT.
YEAH I HAD THE HONOR OF BEING A
PUBLIC MEMBER THE COURTS WERE
LIVING YEARS. NOT MY TENURE ON
THE BOARD I'VE BEEN PROUD OF
OUR STEADFAST COMMITMENT TO
CONSUMER PROTECTION. THAT OUR
ROLE AS A LEADER. THE BORDERS
ARE CONSUMER PROTECTION AGENCY
CHARGED WITH REGULATING THE
BUSINESSES PEOPLE AND PRODUCTS
THROUGH THIS DRUG SUPPLY CHAIN.
UNTIL THE PRODUCT IS EITHER
DISPENSED TO THE PATIENT BY A
PHARMACIST OR PROVIDED TO.
DESCRIBE FOR DISPENSING. THE
VERY ABILITY REGULATION IS
SIGNIFICANT AND COMPLEX
ENCOMPASSES A MERRY OUT OF
STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS TO
ENSURE THAT PATIENTS RECEIVE
SAFE AND EFFICACIOUS MEDICATION.
IN ADDITION TO EVALUATION AND
DISPENSING OF MEDICATIONS THE
ROLE OF THE PHARMACIST IS A
LONGER TERM CAMPUS EVEN GREATER
PATIENT CARE SERVICE. OVER THE
YEARS US POLICY MAKERS HAVE
RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO CARE AND THEY
OPPORTUNITIES- PHARMACISTS HAVE
MORE FULLY USE THE EDUCATION
AND EXPERIENCE GAINED AS PART
OF THEIR PHARMACY EDUCATION.
SUCH EXPANSION IS BOTH
APPROPRIATE AND CONSISTENT WITH
IMPROVED ACCESS TO CARE. FOR
EXAMPLE THE PHARMACIST NOT
PROVIDE MEDICATION THERAPY
MANAGEMENT SERVICES AND THEY
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO INITIATE
MODIFIERS AND DISCONTINUES
THERAPY USED IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE PRESCRIBED. MORE
RECENTLY PHARMACIST WE'RE GOING
TO BE AUTHORITY TO FURNISH FREE
EXPOSURE AND POST EXPOSURE
PROPHYLAXIS UNDER SPECIFIED
CONDITIONS. THE PROVISIONS OF
THE STATUTE REQUIRED THE BOARD
TO ADOPT EMERGENCY REGULATIONS
BY JULY. ONE TWENTY TWENTY.
LATEST REPORT THEM WITH THE
COLLABORATION OF STAKEHOLDERS
EXPERTS IN THE FIELD IN THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS BECAME A
FACTOR APRIL THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY. JUDGE TIME WHERE
ACTIONS YOU BIRDS THE BUS OF
THE WAY. INCREASE ACCESS OR- AS
THE NEW CONTINUES TO GRAPPLE
WITH- OGUN DUNES THE BORDERS TO
AMONG FOR APPROACH COMBAT WE
HAVE TO. INCLUDING ESTABLISHING
REQUIREMENTS YOUR INSURER
BETTER MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
PROMULGATING REGULATIONS
ESTABLISHING A PROTOCOL FOR
PHARMACISTS TO FURNISH NALOXONE
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIVERS
EFFECTS OF A DRUG OVERDOSE.
PROVIDING FREE TRAINING ON
COURSE RESPONSIBILITY AND
RELATED TOPICS AS WELL AS MORE
RECENTLY WORKING WITH EXPERTS
IN THE FIELD TO DEVELOP AND
MAKE VAILABLE A SAMPLE
COLLABORATIVE AGREEMENT
INCREASING ACCESS POINTS FOR
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT.
IN GENERAL SUCH AN AGREEMENT
PROVIDES THE ABILITY FOR
PHARMACISTS TO PERFORM DRUG
THERAPY MANAGEMENT TO PATIENTS
WITH OPIOID USE DISORDER IN
COLLABORATION WITH PRESCRIBERS.
I BELIEVE AN IMPORTANT TO ALSO
HIGHLIGHT THE ACTION THE BOARD
IS TAKEN AS PART OF ITS
RESPONSE TO THE GOVERNMENT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THE BOARD
HAS RELIED HEAVILY ON ITS
EXTRAORDINARY STORIES TO ISSUE
WAIVERS TO PROVISIONS OF
PHARMACY LAW AND ITS
REGULATIONS. ON THE BOARDS.
RELATED THE PROJECT OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE PROVISION OF
PATIENT CARE. IS RESIDENTS OF
SORRY THE BORN INSTAGRAM QUICK
ACTIONS I AM PROUD OF THE BOARD
JACK. AND I KNOW THERE BEEN
MEETING BASED ON NUMERO
ACCOLADES WE'VE RECEIVED FOR
OUR QUICK RESPONSE TO WAIVER
REQUESTS. SIMILAR TO THE
STATE'S RESPONSE REPORTS
RESPONSES INVOLVED DURING THE
PANDEMIC. PARTNERING WITH OTHER
AGENCIES WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND STAKEHOLDERS.
BEEN SIGNIFICANT. R. S. ARE
ONGOING AND INVOLVED IS NATION
AND CALIFORNIA RISK CAN DO. AND
THE EVENTUAL JUST OF. ALL
ROBERT MERRY MEN PLACE THERE
ARE MEN JOHN YOU HAVE. YOUR
CURRENT AMONG THEM MAY IT I'M
OF THE BOARD. I THANK YOU THE
ARE TO SHARE OF THOSE ARE
DURING THE PAST FIVE. TO
FULFILL CONSUMER MANDATE WILL
FORWARD TO CAN OUR WITH A- THEN
MINISTRY. AND STAKEHOLDERS AS
WE FURTHER OBJECTION OF
CALIFORNIA CAN CONSUMERS. THANK
YOU FOR ACCORDING.
OPPORTUNITIES BIG TIER NINE- AM
I WANNA LET YOU KNOW HOW I'M
NOT LINE IS SENATOR GRAMM.
RECORD ABOUT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR THE AND MR GRAMM LOOKS
YEAR TO NOW. AT YOU FOR THE TO-
AND TODAY- AND ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD AND PRESIDENT LIBBY WE
TRULY APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
SUPPORT THAT WE HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED BY BOTH THE
ADMINISTRATION THE LEGISLATURE
AND STAKEHOLDERS AS THE BOARD
WORKS DILIGENTLY TO RESPOND TO
THE CLUB IN NINETEEN CRISIS.
THE ACTIONS THAT WE HAVE TAKEN
BOTH- IT TO PROVIDE WAIVERS AS
WELL AS TO TRANSITION BOTH ARE
OPERATIONS HAVE BEEN QUITE
SIGNIFICANT AND OUR STAFF HAD
DEMONSTRATED RESILIENCY WE HAVE
TRIED TO BE VERY MINDFUL OF THE
IMPACTS THE BOARD IS TAKING TO
ENSURE THAT WE BOTH. CONTINUE
TO MEET OUR CONSUMER PROTECTION
MANDATE WHILE ALSO PROVIDING
THE SAME LEVEL OF SERVICE TO
BOTH CONSUMERS AND APPLICANTS
AND LICENSEES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR GRAMM I'D LIKE TO INVITE
TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WHO
HAVE QUESTIONS TO PLEASE SO
INDICATE SO WE CAN BE
RECOGNIZED. ANY- MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS. CARILLO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CHAIR GLAZIER OD AND
SPECIFICALLY TO THAT OF OUR
BOARD PRESIDENT EXECUTIVE
OFFICER AND TO THE- IMPORTANT
WORK OF THE BOARD ITSELF MUCH
OF IT IS VOLUNTEER BASED AND
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF OUR
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PUBLIC SERVICE.
SPECIFICALLY TO THE ISSUE THAT
HAS BEEN RAISED ISSUE NUMBER
TWO WITH RESPECT TO BOARD
EXPERTISE IT'S BEEN A DAY-
BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION WITH
RESPECT TO THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE EXPERIENCE- WITH
RESPECT TO- PRACTICING
COMPOUNDING- THE THAT OF THE
EXPERIENCE OF. SPECIFICALLY
THAT HAS BEEN ADDRESSED AN
ISSUE NUMBER TWO- TO BE UPDATED
POTENTIALLY TO REQUIRE WHEN THE
PHARMACIST ON THE BOARD TO BE
PRACTICING TO BE A PRACTICING A
COMPOUNDING PHARMACIST- DUE TO
SOME OF THESE ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN ADDRESSED AND REYES AND
AGAIN ISSUE NUMBER TWO. OF MY
DAY EXECUTIVE OFFICER AND BOARD
PRESIDENT ADDRESS. THAT ISSUE
AGAIN ISSUE NUMBER TWO. I THINK
YOU- IN GENERAL I WOULD SEE
THAT THE BOARD REALLY LOOKS
FORWARD TO REVIEWING ALL OF THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AND PROVIDING
RESPONSES BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE THE BOARD ITSELF
HAS NOT HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS THE ISSUE- I WOULD SAY
THAT IN GENERAL THE BOARD WORKS
VERY HARD TO DO ALL OF ITS
DELIBERATIONS AND PUBLIC
PROVIDES A VERY ROBUST
OPPORTUNITY FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
PARTICIPATE AND ENGAGE. THE
BOARD ALSO REACHES OUT TO
EXPERTS AS WELL WHEN THEY
BELIEVE THAT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION IS NECESSARY- THERE
ARE SEVERAL PHARMACIST
POSITIONS ON THE BOARD- SOME OF
WHICH ARE NOT CURRENTLY-
DEDICATED OR ALLOCATED TO A
SPECIFIC POSITION SO I DO
BELIEVE UNDER THE CURRENT
STATUTORY AUTHORITY- SOMEONE
WITH A COMPOUNDING BACKGROUND
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO APPLY- FOR
AN APPOINTMENT. BUT UNTIL THE
BOARD HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
FULLY DISCUSS THE ISSUE IT DOES
NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION
ON THAT ISSUE. GREAT THANK YOU
IT AND THEN THE SECOND QUESTION
IF I MIGHT MISS CARE. THIS IS
WITH RESPECT TO ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTEEN- WITH RESPECT TO SOME
OF THE RETAIL PHARMACY
PENALTIES. ED SPECIFICALLY DOES
THE BOARD BELIEVE THAT YOU
SHOULD HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
IMPOSE HARSHER PENALTIES FOR
VIOLATIONS OF LAW ACROSS
MULTIPLE PHARMACIES OPERATING
UNDER COMMONOWNERSHIP AND
DISCUSSED IN THE BACKGROUND
PAPER. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND AGAIN
THE BOARD WILL BE DISCUSSING
THIS ISSUE IN MORE DETAIL- IN
RESPONSE TO THE BACKGROUND
PAPER AND WILL BE PROVIDING A
RESPONSE IN GENERAL THERE ARE
SOME CHALLENGES WITH-
EFFECTUATE IN- COMPLIANCE WITH
THE AREAS THAT SEEM TO BE MORE
SYSTEMIC THAN A SITE SPECIFIC
ISSUE. SO THE BOARD IS LOOKING
FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO BE- IT
SHOULD BE ADAM. TO BE ABLE TO
FACILITATE THE NECESSARY
PATIENT PROTECTIONS PERHAPS IN
A MORE BROAD SENSE THAN JUST
AND A SPECIFIC SITE- AS YOU
KNOW THERE ARE LARGE- RETAIL
CHAINS AS WELL AS INDEPENDENT
PHARMACIES AND- THE NATURE OF
HOW WE CAN RESPOND TO THEM IS
CURRENTLY THE SAME AND THE
BOARD BELIEVES THAT THERE MAY
BE OPPORTUNITY TO- ADD SOME
ADDITIONAL OPTIONS TO ITS-
TOOLBOX TO MORE EFFECTIVELY
PROMOTE ITS CONSUMER PROTECTION
MANDATE. GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU CHAIR LOW- ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
SENATOR PAN HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS- THANK YOU- CHECK
LATER AND- APPRECIATE-
DISCUSSION I'D I'D COUPLE
QUESTIONS- IN REGARDS TO. WAS
PRESENTED IN THAT BACKGROUND
PAPER- SO FIRST OF ALL- THIS IS
A QUESTION GENERALLY ASK A LOT
OF BOARDS- DISHING HEALTH
PROFESSIONS ON CONTINUING
EDUCATION I APPRECIATE THAT
ACTUALLY- THE TEARS THAT
COMPLIANCE IS BEEN GOING UP
OVER TIME BASS AND- THAT- FOR
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY- THAT-
THE NUMBER OF AUDITS THAT
PERFORMED- HAS DROPPED
SIGNIFICANTLY I DON'T KNOW
THERE'S THAT REALLY TO COVET OR
SOMETHING OR WHAT CHANGE IS AN
EXPLANATION. WHY THAT FOR THAT
SIGNIFICANT DROP IN AUDITS. IS
STILL IN CARD- AS WE'VE HAD TO
RE DIRECT STAFF IN SOME AREAS
WE'VE HAD TO- YOU KNOW AND MAKE
SOME. DECISIONS ON WHERE BEST
TO DIRECT RESOURCES SO WE HAVE
pHAD TO SCALE BACK OUR EFFORTS
IN THAT AREA WE ARE LOOKING AT
OTHER OPTIONS AS WELL- TO
PERHAPS. USE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PLATFORMS TO CONDUCT AUDITS BUT
UNTIL WE'RE ABLE TO EFFECTUATE
THAT IT IS STILL A MANUAL
PROCESS. OKAY SO. JUST TO
CLARIFY YOU SAID YOU HAD TO
SHIFT STAFFS OF- IS THIS CHANGE
WHICH BASICALLY GONE FROM SIX
HUNDRED TWELVE I MEAN WE'VE HAD
OVER SIX HUNDRED AUDITS FOR THE
LAST THREE YEARS. UNTIL THE
PREVIOUS YEAR WORDS TO ONLY TWO
HUNDRED AUTHORED. IS THAT A OF
A PERMANENT IS THAT AN ONGOING
CHANGE BECAUSE OF STAFF FIFTEEN
HOURS- TEMPORARY EVENTS TO
HAPPEN FOR TWENTY NINETEEN TO
TWENTY WHERE WE HAD A- DROPPED
BY A THIRD MY EXTRA TWO THIRDS
OF WE'VE ONLY CONNECTING. ONE
THIRTY AUDITS THAT WERE DONE IN
THE PRIOR THREE YEARS. ALSO
FROM THE FROM A PROCESS
STANDPOINT WE WERE ALWAYS
TRYING TO BALANCE- OUR WORK
LIVES AND TRYING TO- RESPOND TO
DIFFERENT TYPES OF ISSUE SO
IT'S IN PART TO KOPEN- ARE
RESOURCES THAT ARE DEDICATED
ARE SINGLE RESOURCE THAT'S
DEDICATED TO C. E. ON ITS HAS
LOTS OF OTHER FUNCTIONS AS WELL
AND- HAS BEEN A RECENTLY- GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TRANSITION
TO CONTACT TRACING SO WE ARE
LOOKING FOR WAYS TO- AS I SAID
TRY TO AUTOMATE SOME OF THE
FUNCTIONS SO THAT WE CAN GO
BACK TO A MORE ROBUST- C. E.
AUDIT BUT AT THIS POINT- WE
HAVE STAFF WORKING IN VARIOUS
AREAS. OKAY SO I'M GONNA TAKE
THAT IS THE ANSWER IS YES THIS
IS THE ON GOING AT LEAST
CERTAINLY DURING TOTAL BID BUT-
I DON'T KNOW TASK OF IT WE WILL
BE HOPING FOR THE TASK OF A
TIME- THAT I HOPE THAT- YOU
KNOW GIVEN THE NUMBER OF
LICENSEES- AND WHAT PERCENTAGE
THAT REPRESENTS THAT- WE NEED
TO DETERMINE. YOU KNOW WITH FOR
AN EFFECTIVE C. E. PROGRAM
WHAT'S REQUIRED- I WOULD ALSO
MAKE NOTE. OF THAT AND I
APPRECIATE THAT- YOU KNOW THERE
ARE PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATIONS
THAT- ACTUALLY CREDIT THE
CONTINUING EDUCATION PROVIDERS.
I JUST. THE QUESTION ABOUT. I
DO THEY HAVE CONFLICT OF
INTERESTS- POLICIES TO ENSURE
THAT PROCEED- THAT'S BEEN
RECEIVED BY PHARMACIST. IS IT
DID THERE ARE CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST AND RELATED TO THE
MATERIAL THAT- THEY'RE BEING
PROVIDED TO THEIR C. E. I WOULD
NEED TO CONFIRM WITH THE-
PROVIDE ORGANIZATIONS THAT I
BELIEVE THAT THAT IS THE
STANDARD YES OKAY. AGAIN THIS
IS A QUESTION I HAVE ASKED-
USUALLY IF ALMOST EVERY HEALTH
PROFESSIONS BOARD BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT. OUR
PROFESSIONALS ON THE RECEIVING
CREDIT CLINT- CONCERNING
EDUCATION THAT ACTUAR REQUIRING
OF THEM THAT IT'S NOT AND YOU
KNOW SOMETHING THAT. IS
ESSENTIALLY A SALES JOB BY
SOMEONE IN INDUSTRY OR
SOMETHING THAT THAT'S ACTUALLY
CONTINUING EDUCATION SO. I'M
SURE THESE PROFESSIONAL
RELATIONS I SHOULD MAKE HOPE SO
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THE BOARD
SAID. BE SURE THAT THE CASE- SO
I DID SO I JUST APPRECIATE YOU
CAN LAUGH. CHECK UP ON THAT
AND- IF THEY'RE CERTAINLY
THAT'S NOT THE CASE THEN THAT'S
PERHAPS SOMETHING THE BOARD
SHOULD ADDRESS- THE OTHER THING
THAT- ALSO WANT TO. ASK ABOUT
IT I NOTED IN THE BACKGROUND
PAPER- IT WAS REFERENCE MADE TO
WORK FOR STUDY- WHERE DOES
ACTUALLY EVEN- CONCERNED IT MAY
BE AN OVERSUPPLY OF PHARMACISTS
ALTHOUGH I THINK THAT GIVEN THE
NEED OUT THERE. I HAD AN CHANCE
LOOK THE STUDY ITSELF BUT- IT.
I KNOW WE'VE ALSO TALK ABOUT
THE ROLE OF PHARMACISTS IN
TERMS OF SERVICE SUPERVISING
PHARMACY TAX. IS THE BOARD-%
EVERY CONSIDER DOING SOME SORT
OF WORK FORCE EVALUATION TO BE
SURE OUR OUR WORKLOAD
EVALUATION IN TERMS OF- BE SURE
THAT PHARMACISTS WHO ARE OUT IN
THE FIELD THAT- THAT THEY'RE
NOT- THAT BASICALLY THEY HAVE
THE- TIME TO. CONDUCT A WORK I
KNOW YOU CERTAINLY GET- TO
ADDRESS ISSUES OF COMPLAINTS OR
PROBLEMS THAT COME UP. IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT THE BOARD LOOKS
AT TO BE SURE THAT- READ OF
SOME OF THE PROBLEMS ISN'T
BECAUSE OF EITHER EXCESSIVE
WORKLOAD OR- EXCESSIVE
SUPERVISION RESPONSIBILITIES
THAT LEAD TO POTENTIAL EITHER
ERRORS OR- ARE HARMED ITS CARS
SO IS THAT SOMETHING THE BOARD
LOOKED AT. THE BOARD ITSELF HAS
NOT CONDUCTED ANY OF THOSE-
TYPES OF STUDIES THERE ARE SOME
OUT THERE- BUT NOT SPECIFIC TO
CALIFORNIA BUT I AM AWARE. OF
SOME OF WHAT YOU'RE SPEAKING TO
ALSO SPEAKS TO THE ISSUE
REGARDING MEDICATION ERRORS.
AND THAT THE BOARD HAS NOT HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW- THAT
THE BACKGROUND PAPER AND ISSUES
BUT- I BELIEVE THAT THAT MAY BE
ONE AREA THAT ALSO BLEEDS OVER
INTO MEDICATION ERRORS AND- I
WOULD EXPECT THAT THE BOARD
WILL CONSIDER WHETHER OR NOT IT
SHOULD BE- CONDUCTING A STUDY.
OR WORKING WITH PERHAPS SOME OF
THE ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS
WITHIN CALIFORNIA TO CONDUCT
THOSE KINDS OF STUDIES OKAY I
THINK THAT WOULD BE. IMPORTANT
TO YOU KNOW THE BOARD GAME
PLAYING THE ROLE OF THE
PROTECTOR OF THE CONSUMER- IT
NEEDS TO BE SURE THAT THE WORK
ENVIRONMENT WHICH PHARMACISTS
ARE WORKING ALLOWS THEM TO DO
THEIR JOB APPROPRIATELY AND HAD
DIFFERENT DATA FIND PROBLEMS L.
DOING THAT ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS.
AND BE SURE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
WORKLOAD ISSUES THAT ARE
LEADING TO ISSUE PROBLEMS WE
ARE ASKING MORE OF OUR
PHARMACISTS- AND- THERE ON THE
FRONT LINES AND THEY'RE VERY
THEY'RE VALUED MEMBERS OF THE
HEALTHCARE TEAM WHO DO VERY
IMPORTANT THINGS AND WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THEM. GIVE
COVETED IMMUNIZATIONS HOPEFULLY
AS A WAY TO IMPROVE ACCESS FOR
THAT AS WELL AS OTHER. TYPES OF
VERY IMPORTANT SERVICES AND-
ALSO. I THINK THERE'S BEEN A
DESIRE TO HAVE THEM DO MORE
POTENTIALLY SCREENINGS OR OTHER
TYPES OF THINGS MEDICATION
MANAGEMENT. AND BUT THOSE ALSO
COME WITH GREATER
RESPONSIBILITIES AND GREATER
TIME AND SO WE NEED TO BE SURE
THAT. AS WE'RE ROLLING THESE
OUT THE BOARD IN THIS ROLE IS
TO PUT NO CONSUMER PROTECTION-
THAT IF IT. TO IDENTIFY ITS-
THE WORKING FOR. OF WITH THE
REST OF. WE GIVE FARM. IN A WAY
THAT- THEY CAN PERFORM THEIR-
JOBS- SAFELY AND CERTAINLY IS
PROFESSIONALS I KNOW
PHARMACISTS WILL SPEAK OUT OF
THE SEA THERE'S PROBLEMS BUT-
ALSO. I THINK THE BOARD HAS A
ROLE AND- AND INTERACTING UP
THOSE PHARMACISTS TO ENSURE
THAT- AFTER THE WORK CONDITIONS
ALLOW THEM TO. TO CONDUCT
THEMSELVES IN THE WAY THAT THEY
THEY WERE THAT THEY DESIRE AS
PROFESSIONALS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR PAN AND- APPRECIATE
YOUR THOUGHTFUL QUESTIONS AND
NOT. CERTAIN THAT THE- THE
BOARD WILL PROVIDE INPUT- ON
THIS CONFLICT OF INTEREST
QUESTION THAT- THEY WERE NOT
ABLE TO ANSWER TODAY SO ASK
YOUR STAFF TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT.
OTHER QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KING. THE
CARICATURE JUST A QUICK
QUESTION REGARDING SOME OF THE
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS I DID
NOTICE- ON IN JUST ON THE PAGE
THIRTEEN OF THE REPORT. I GUESS
OF REDUCTION IN THE NUMBER OF
INVESTIGATIONS CLOSED- FOR
ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED TO
ABOUT TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED AND ALSO I DON'T
KNOW IF THERE'S A CORRELATION
BUT ALSO A- REDUCTION IN THE
NUMBER OF- CONVICTIONS OR- YOU
KNOW CITATIONS THAT WERE
INVOLVED FROM MEMBERS SO COULD
YOU WALK US THROUGH BY THE
REDUCTION IN THE NUMBER OF
INVESTIGATIONS. EXCELLENT HARD
IT IS A FUNCTION OF THAT
COMPLAINTS THAT WE RECEIVED-
IT'S ALSO IN PART THE TYPES OF
INVESTIGATIONS THAT WERE DOING
THAT SOMETIMES ARE VERY COMPLEX
ELKS IN IF YOU LOOK AT OUR
INVESTIGATION CASE TIMES
THEY'RE ALSO A LITTLE BIT
LONGER THAN WE WOULD- LIKE. AND
IN PART IT'S BECAUSE OF THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE TYPES OF
CASES. THE BOARD HAS WORKED
REALLY HARD TO FOCUS ON
EDUCATION- IN ADDITION TO
ENFORCEMENT AND- HOW PART OF IT
COULD BE THE RESULT OF THE
BOARD'S EDUCATION EFFORTS WE
PROVIDE- C. E. AND A NUMBER OF
IMPORTANT AREAS. INCLUDING
PHARMACY LAW AND ETHICS WE ALSO
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT TRAINING
WITH- PRESCRIPTION DRUG ABUSE
PREVENTION CORRESPONDING
RESPONSIBILITY. PREVENTING
FACTS AND LOSSES AND THOSE ARE
ALL CORD PROVIDED TRAINEES WE
ALSO ARE TRYING TO DO A LOT
MORE IN TERMS OF EDUCATION
USING OUR SUBSCRIBER ALERT
SYSTEM AND OUR NEWSLETTER. SO I
THINK IT COULD BE A COMBINATION
OF A LOT OF DIFFERENT ITEMS.
THE TICKET A QUICK FOLLOW UP-
SO YOU SAID YOU NOTED THAT
THERE ABOUT TWELVE THOUSAND
INVEST. BUT TWO THOUSAND
DESTINATIONS OVER THE- THREE
YEAR PERIOD. WAS THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT FLUCTUATION FROM
YEAR TO YEAR. I WOULD HAVE TO
PULL THE DATA WERE IN THE
PROCESS OF FINALIZING OUR
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT THAT WILL
BE SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE
OUR- SUPPLEMENTAL RESPONSE.
THAT WILL BE SUBMITTED ON
DECEMBER FIRST AFFECTS
AGREEABLE YES THAT THAT IS
THANK YOU- I JUST JUST WANNA
JUST HIGHLIGHT WHY I'M ASKING
THE QUESTIONS I MEAN FOR. FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AS WE GO
THROUGH THIS SUNSET HEARINGS IN
WE HEAR. ALL THE VERY US
DIFFERENT- BOARDS WE COSTLY
HERE FROM FAMILIES THAT ARE
STRUGGLING WITH. SUBSTANCE
ABUSE OR FRIDAY OF ISSUES AND
SO OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT ALL THE- DIFFERENT BOARDS
ARE DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
THAT THEY CAN ON THE MATTER FOR
MET. THE CHALLENGE TO- WE WILL
BE HERE YOU KNOW HUNDREDS OF
FAMILIES COME IN DURING THESE.
TIMES AT TIMES DURING HEARINGS
BUT ALSO DURING COMMITTEE
TIMES. DURING VARIOUS COMMITTEE
HEARINGS ABOUT JUST THE VARIETY
OF WAYS THAT- YOU KNOW PEOPLE
THEIR THEIR FAMILY MEMBER SLIP
THROUGH THE CRACKS I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO PROPERLY
DO THE. ENFORCEMENT THAT WERE
ASKED TO DO. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TANG. I WOULD INVITE ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WHO ARE JOINING
US REMOTELY LEFT QUESTIONS TO
PLEASE THAT USED TO RAISE YOUR
HAND FUNCTION SO YOU CAN BE
RECOGNIZE OTHERWISE I WILL.
HAVE SOME MORE QUESTIONS FROM
THE CHAMBERS BUT JUST WANNA.
I'LL BEGIN MY QUESTIONS. AND
IF- THERE IS A MEMBER WHO HAS A
QUESTION A LOT WILL CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE YOU IN AN AND
FOLLOWING MY QUESTIONS AND
THERE'S WILL GO TO THE PUBLIC
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AS WELL.
RIGHT- AT MINNESOTA GRIN AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU FOR THE
RESPONSIVENESS OF THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED IN THE
STAFF AND ALICE'S I HAVE A
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS FIRST ONE-
THERE WAS LEGISLATION LAST YEAR
DEALING WITH THE FARM TECH
RATIO ISSUE- AND THE BOARD AT
THAT TIME HAD DID NOT WEIGH IN
WITH A THOUGHT ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT THE CURRENT RATIO OF ONE TO
ONE IS APPROPRIATE AND WHETHER
UNDER CERTAIN CONDITIONS.
SHOULD BE EXPANDED DO YOU HAVE
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS ON THAT OR
IS THERE STUDIES BEING DONE BY
THE BOARD IN THIS IN THIS ISSUE.
I SO THE BOARD DOES NOT. EXCUSE
ME DOES NOT HAVE A POSITION- I
WOULD SAY THAT IT'S A WIN- TO.
HE BACK IN ON SOME OF WHAT AND
DOCTOR PANTS FACT ABOUT AS
PHARMACIST ARE GIVEN ADDITIONAL-
YOU KNOW AUTHORITIES THERE'S A
BALANCING ACT THAT NEEDS TO
OCCUR TO ENSURE THAT- HAITIANS
ARE STILL RECEIVING ALL OF THE
NECESSARY CARE. AND WORKLOAD IS
IF HE SAID THAT AS A MEDICATION
THERE'S A LOTS OF OTHER THINGS
SO I THINK THAT ITSELF IT'S A
HOLISTIC COMPLICATED ISSUE THAT
NEEDS TO BE EVALUATED- THERE'S
BEEN YOU KNOW DISCUSSIONS IN
THE MEDIA ABOUT MEDICATION
ERRORS. AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE POTENTIAL WITH THE RATIONS
AND WHAT THOSE LOOK LIKE- IT
NEEDS TO BE BELIEVE THE BOARD
WILL BE. LOOKING AT THE ISSUE
IN A VERY DELIBERATE IN FASHION
TO SEE IF AN INCREASE IN THE
RATIO WOULD ACTUALLY- AT
ADDRESS WHAT COULD BE. BE
WORKFORCE CHALLENGES FOR
FURTHER- JUST WORK THE PHARMACY
TO BE DO. BY INCREASE THE LAW
OF- THE NUMBER OF THAT ARE ALSO
REQUIRED SUPERVISION. WELL I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION- BUT I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO TRY TO
BRING THAT ISSUE TO A HEAD AND
PROVIDE EXPERTISE TO US. ON
MATTERS SUCH AS THIS A WEEKEND
THAT TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT IN
DECIDING WHETHER OR NOT WE WANT
TO MAKE CHANGES SO I WOULD JUST
TO LIGHT A FIRE. UNDER YOUR
WORK THERE- WE SHARE THE SAME
GOALS AND VALUES AND ENSURING-
PATIENT CARE IS AT THE HIGHEST
LEVEL. AT THE SAME TIME- WE
WANT OUR PHARMACISTS TO BE ABLE
TO DO THEIR BEST WORK. AND
SOMETIMES THAT DOESN'T MEAN
HAVING THE- CHIEF PHARMACISTS
DO EVERYTHING- IN TERMS OF
COUNTING PILLS THAT CAN BE DONE
BY. A PERSON WHO'S BEEN
PROPERLY TRAINED BUT HAVE- THE
ABILITY TO TAKE OVER THOSE
RESPONSIBILITIES TO FREE UP
THAT PHARMACISTS FOR MORE
SUBSTANTIAL- ISSUE SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR- CONTINUED
REVIEW OF THAT LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR FEEDBACK. I'D LIKE TO TURN
TO- PAGE THIRTY FOR THE
ANALYSIS WORD ADDRESSES THE
ISSUE OF- THE ISSUES- REGARDING
KOBE NINETEEN AND- YOU DID
SPEAK IN YOUR TESTIMONY ABOUT
SOME OF THAT. A TEMPORARY
LICENSES AND- THAT MATTERS THAT
YOU HAVE ENGAGED IN- IN REGARD
TO IT IN CALIFORNIA. MY
QUESTION IS- LUCKILY THROUGH
THE GOOD STEWARDSHIP OF
GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND HIS TEAM.
WE HAVE NOT BEEN OVER RUN WITH
KOBE CASES WE ARE AT IT IS
SERIOUS AB. THE POINT OF
CONCERN IN REGARD TO INFECTIONS
GOING UP. DRAMATICALLY NOW. AS
THEY DID IN THE SUMMER- BUT WE
HAVEN'T ARE OUR OUR MEDICAL
SYSTEMS HAVE NOT BEEN OVER RUN
AS THEY HAD BEEN IN OTHER
STATES. HAVE YOU HAD A CHANCE
TO LOOK AT THE DELIVERY OF
PHARMACY SERVICES AND SOME OF
THESE STATES THAT HAVE
EXPERIENCED THAT. EXTREME
IMPACT OF COVERT NINETEEN TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT KIND OF LESSONS
WE CAN LEARN FROM THEIR
EXPERIENCES SO THAT. IF THINGS
WERE TO GET WORSE HERE THAT. WE
WOULD BE PREPARED AS WE COULD
BE FROM- THE- OUR HEALTH
DELIVERY SYSTEM INCLUDING OUR
PHARMACIES. THAT YOU'RE ON MUTE.
EIGHTY I WAS UNABLE TO MEET
STILL AS PART OF OUR COMPANY WE
HAVE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH
KNOWLEDGE AND PARTICIPATING IN
NATIONAL MEETINGS AS WELL WITH
THE OTHER STATE BOARDS OF
PHARMACY- I'M THE LEADING END
OF MANY OF THE RESPONSES AND- I
BELIEVE THAT IN MANY CASES THE
APPROACH THAT WE ARE TAKING HAS
BEEN LEVERAGED BY OTHER
ENTITIES AS WELL. ARE YOU AWARE
OF ANY- IT SERIOUS DEFICIENCIES
THAT HAVE OCCURRED IN THE
DELIVERY OF PHARMACEUTICAL
SERVICES IN IN YORK IN NEW
JERSEY AND OTHER PLACES WHERE
THERE HAVE HAD SERIOUS- RUN OF
COVE IN NINETEEN-
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND THE LIKE.
STILL CALIFORNIA WE STILL HAVE
THE CHALLENGES WITH THAT PP- SO
WE DO HAVE WAIVERS IN EFFECT
THERE IN MANY STATES ACROSS THE
NATION HALF THOSE- EARLY ON
WHEN THERE IS- A LOT OF
CHALLENGES WITH DIRECT
SHORTAGES IN CALIFORNIA WE
ACTUALLY REACHED OUT TO THE
OUTSOURCING FACILITIES- THAT
ARE LICENSED IN CALIFORNIA AND
WE DEVELOPED A LIST OF PRODUCTS
THAT WERE AVAILABLE TO MAKE IT-
SO THAT HOSPITALS ESPECIALLY
THAT WE'RE NEEDING- MEDICATIONS
TO TAKE CARE OF PATIENTS WOULD
HAVE ACCESS TO THEM. IT'S
ALWAYS A BALANCING ACT- BUT WE
WERE VERY PROACTIVE IN DOING
THAT AND ENSURING THAT THERE
WAS RESOURCES AVAILABLE- SO
THAT HOSPITALS ESPECIALLY WOULD
BE ABLE TO KNOW WHERE TO GO
WITH RESPECT TO DISTRACTIONS
IN- AT PRESCRIPTION MEDICATION.
EARLY ON IN THE PANDEMIC THERE
WERE CONCERNS ABOUT-
HYDROCHLORIC NGUYEN AND
ATTENTIONAL SHORTAGES THERE. ON
THE BOARD WORKED WITH BOTH THE
MEDICAL BOARD AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
AND WE RE LEASED- A STATEMENT
REMINDING BOTH PRESCRIBERS AND
DISPENSERS ABOUT THE STANDARD
OF CARE IN TO BE FOLLOWING THE
APPROPRIATE STANDARD OF CARE.
AND THEIR PROFESSIONAL
OBLIGATIONS THERE ARE SOME
STATES THAT TOOK ACTIONS TO
ACTUALLY- RESTRICT- MEDICATION
DISPENSING IN CERTAIN AREAS
THAT IS NOT BE APPROACH THAT
WAS TAKEN IN CALIFORNIA. DID
YOU HAVE CONFIDENCE OUR
PHARMACIES ARE CAPABLE OF
DEALING WITH- AN ESCALATION OF.
COVERT NINETEEN VIRUSES AND ALL
THEIR AFFECTS THAT- THAT WILL
AFFECT YOUR INDUSTRY OF
CONFIDENCE THAT YOU HAVE WHAT
THEY HAVE WHAT THEY NEED NOW. I
BELIEVE SO I THINK THAT-
PHARMACIST HAD JUST
DEMONSTRATED TREMENDOUS
RESILIENCY- THROUGH THIS ENTIRE
AND PANDEMICS AND I THINK THAT-
WE HAVE VERY GOOD DIALOGUE WITH
OUR STAKEHOLDERS. AND IF THERE
ARE NEEDS FOR- ADDITIONAL
WAIVERS- THE BOARD IS
DISCUSSING THESE ROUTINELY
DURING BOARD MEETINGS WE ALSO
HAVE OUR WAIVER PROCESS ONLINE
SHOULD A NEED COME UP THAT HAS
NOT PREVIOUSLY BEEN IDENTIFIED.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT CLICK THE
COMMUNICATION THAT WE HAVE
MAINTAINED WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE PROCESSES
THAT WE HAVE. HAS DEMONSTRATED
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO QUICKLY
RESPONDS TO THE VERY DYNAMIC
NATURE AND I BELIEVE THAT THE
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS THAT WE
REGULATE. ARE READY AND WILLING
AND HAVE DEMONSTRATED THEIR
ABILITY TO RESPOND TO THE
HEALTH CRISIS THANK YOU THAT'S
COMFORTING TO HEAR IS THERE
ENOUGH PP NOW FOR ALL THE
PHARMACIES- FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE
ENOUGH PP. ARBACE ON MY UNDER.
THERE AT THE SUPPLIES BETTER- I
THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME
CHALLENGES WITH SOME- OF THE P.
P. EACH ON SPECIFIC TO THOSE
THAT HAVE SIZING REQUIREMENTS
MAYBE NOT NECESSARILY HAVING
THE RIGHT TYPES OF SIZING- LIKE
I SAID WE DO STILL HAVE OUR
WAIVERS IN PLACE FOUR PP SO
THAT. IF THE CONDITIONS REQUIRE
PEOPLE HAVE THE GOOD-
GUARDRAILS ON WHAT TO DO AND IN
RESPONSE I CANNOT SPEAK TO
OUTSIDE OF COURSE THE PHARMACY
RE NAME ONLY SPEAKING SPECIFIC
TO YOU- PHARMACISTS. IT USED
YOU BELIEVE THAT THIS CHAIN IS
ADEQUATE SO THAT THEY ARE
PROPERLY PROTECTED WITH PP.
STILL I CAN SPEAK TO THE
PHARMACIST AND THE ACTIONS THAT
THE BOARD HAS TAKEN ON IN
ADDITION TO THE WAIVERS FOR THE
RE USE THAT P. P. E. THAT WERE
YOU KNOW MODELED AFTER-
EXPERIENCE- IN THE FIELD WE
ALSO WORKED TO ISSUE TEMPORARY
LICENCES TO FACILITATE-
DISTRIBUTION OF P. P. E. AS
WELL AS BETTER LEADERS INTO THE
STATE. BY EXPANDING THE
CAPACITY OF DISTRIBUTORS THAT
COULD PROVIDE THOSE PRODUCTS
INTO AND WITHIN CALIFORNIA. BUT
I APPRECIATE HEARING THAT I AND
I'M SURE PROVIDE SOME LEVEL OF
COMFORT TO LISTENERS AND OTHERS
WHO ARE WATCHING WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN OUR WORLD AND IN
OUR STATE. ON IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO HAVE THE BOARD AT BE
PROACTIVE IN THESE PLACES- TO.
ADD TO THE CONFIDENCE SCALE
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THAT
WE ARE PREPARED AS WE CAN BE.
I'D LIKE TO MOVE NOW TO ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN- THE DRESSING PAGE
TWENTY FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS
THAT ADVANCE PHARMACY
TECHNICIANS- THE BOARD'S
INDICATED THAT THEY'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN DISCUSSIONS
REGARDING- THE LICENSE TYPE
PREVENTS PHARMACY TECHNICIANS-
AND THE QUESTION THAT STAFF HAS
RAISED AS TO WHETHER OR NOT-
THAT. THAT CONSTRUCTIVE
DIALOGUE WITH STAKEHOLDERS AT
WHAT PLACE ARE WE WITH IN THAT.
SUBJECT AREA COULD YOU ADDRESS
THAT IN TERMS OF HOW FAR ALONG
YOU ARE IN. ENGAGING AND WHAT'S
THE STATUS OF THAT PLEASE.
ABSOLUTELY SO THE BOARD'S
LICENSING COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
THE BOARD ITSELF HAS CONVENED
AT NUMEROUS MEETINGS TO DISCUSS
THIS PROPOSAL. ON THE BOARD-
WAS IN THE PROCESS OF
FINALIZING IT AND RECEIVED-
SOME. ADDITIONAL STAKEHOLDER
COMMENT EXPRESSING CONCERNS AN
ASSET TO THE BOARD DECIDED TO-
SCHEDULE AN ADDITIONAL MEETING
TO ALLOW FOR ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR DISCUSSION.
REGRETTABLY THAT MEETING WAS
CANCELED IT WAS ACTING VERY
BEGINNING- IT WAS SCHEDULED FOR
MARCH AT THE VERY BEGINNING OF
THE PANDEMIC. AND SINCE THEN
THE BOARD HAS NOT HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THIS
DISCUSSION ON THE ADVANCED
PHARMACY TECHNICIAN. BUT I DO
THINK THAT THE PROPOSAL- IS- IN
SOME RESPECTS LINK TO YOUR
PRIOR QUESTION WITH RESPECT TO
RATIOS- THE APPROACH OF THE
ADVANCED PHARMACY TECHNICIAN
WOULD BE PROVIDING AND THE MID
LEVEL PRACTITIONER THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE LIGHTENING THE
LOAD. FOR PHARMACIST IN PERHAPS
A DIFFERENT FASHION- THE RATIO
IN ITSELF CHANGE. WE APPRECIATE
THAT THAT WORK AND WE HOPE THAT
YOU'LL CONTINUE IT AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT- FEEDBACK TO
US- ON THIS- IN THAT AREA. I'D
LIKE TO MOVED OUT TO ISSUE
NUMBER. ELEVEN ON PAGE TWENTY
SEVEN THIS IS TO MATTER
REGARDING THE EXAMINATION- AND
THE RECENT CHEATING SCANDAL
THAT OCCURRED- IN REGARD TO THE
EXAMINATION. AND I'D LIKE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW AND THE IMPACT
ON STUDENTS- OBVIOUSLY EVERY
STUDENT WAS INVOLVED IN THAT
THERE WERE SOME- INNOCENT.
PARTIES INVOLVED THAT WERE
CAUGHT UP IN IT DO YOU HAVE ANY
SENSE OF THE CONSEQUENCES OF
THAT FOR THE STUDENTS AND WHAT
PROTECTIONS THAT WE HAVE NOW IN
PLACE TO ENSURE THAT. THE EXAM
IS- IS DONE. FAIRLY AND
CORRECTLY AND THAT THAT'S KIND
OF DISRUPTION. IN THE LIVES OF
THESE- SOON TO BE. PHARMACISTS
IS MINIMIZED. HERE I MEET
AGAIN. YEAH I SORRY SOMETIMES
I'M UNABLE TO MEET- YOU'D SAID
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
WITH THAT- WHAT HAPPENED WITH
THE CTG IS- A TRAGEDY- IT WAS.
EXTREMELY UNFORTUNATE EVENT BY
THE BOARD DID NOT HAVE ANY
OPTIONS- PART OF THE BASIC
PREMISES SEVEN EXAM IS THAT IT
NEEDS TO BE FAIR THE BOARD USES
THE CPJ HE ASKED ONE OF THE-
PRIMARY TEST FOR ASSESSING
MINIMUM COMPETENCY. BEFORE
ALLOWING SOMEONE TO ENTER THE
MARKET PLACE AND GIVEN THE
WIDESPREAD COMPROMISE. OF THE
EXAM THE EXAM WAS NO LONGER
VALID THE BOARD DIDN'T HAVE
DIDN'T HAVE ANY GOOD OPTIONS.
WHAT IT DID DO IS MOVE VERY
QUICKLY TO RE ADMINISTERING THE
EXAM. THE INVESTIGATION ITSELF
I WILL TELL YOU IS ON GOING- I
CANNOT GO INTO A LOT OF
SPECIFICS BECAUSE IT IS ONGOING
BUT- THE BOARD HAS DISCIPLINED-
SOME LICENSES. THE BOARD ALSO
BELIEVES THAT HE HAS A GOOD
CONTROLS IN PLACE. TO MINIMIZE
THE EXPOSURE TO PREVENT THE
WIDESPREAD SUBVERSION WHAT IS
HAPPENING. ON AS WAS REVEALED
THROUGH OUR IN. ALSO IN
ADDITION TO THAT THIS ISSUE
ITSELF THE BOARD IS ALSO
WORKING THE OFFICE OF FOR EXAM.
SERVICES WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS TO CONDUCT
AN AUDIT OF- THE PHARMACIST
EXAMS AND IF THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL CHANGES THAT ARE
pTHE BOARD WILL ABSOLUTELY
CONSIDER AS- VERY GOOD THANK
YOU FOR THAT- EXPLANATION AND-
ATTENTION TO THAT TO THAT
MATTER. I'D LIKE TO MOVE NOW TO
ISSUE NUMBER SIXTEEN ON PAGE
THIRTY- THIS IS THE ISSUE OF-
THE DYNAMAX DECISION AND ITS
EFFECTS ON THE PHARMACY
PROFESSION- AS I UNDERSTAND IT
THE PHARMACISTS WERE NOT GIVEN
AN EXEMPTION- IN THE- FOLLOW UP
LEGISLATION AB FIVE AND OTHERS
THAT HAVE. COME IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS. HAS THERE BEEN ANY-
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS WITHIN
THE BOARD ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT.
THE CURRENT- LANDSCAPE OF THE
PROFESSION WOULD REQUIRE AN
EXEMPTION OR NOT- THE BOARD HAS
NOT HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CONSIDER THIS ISSUE OR OR TO
SCHEDULE ANY PUBLIC DISCUSSION-
BUT AFTER THE BOARD REVIEWS THE
ISSUE PAPERS ON WE WILL IT'S
PART OF OUR RESPONSE DETAIL OUT
WHAT THAT- WHAT THE PLAN IS IN
TERMS OF. RESPONDING TO THIS
ISSUE. OKAY I'M GONNA INVITE MR
LIBBY BACK IN A MOMENT TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE MATTERS
THAT SEEM TO BE PENDING THERE
SEEMS TO BE A LOT OF THOSE. I
WANT TO- MOVE NOW TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY THREE- THIS IS
THE- MATTER OF UNUSED CANCER
MEDICATION TRANSFERS- WE'VE
SEEN THAT LEGISLATION IN THE
LAST YEAR FROM SOME OF OUR GOOD
COLLEAGUES IN THE LEGISLATURE.
WHO RECOGNIZE THE EXPENSE OF
CANCER MEDICATION AND THE
POTENTIAL- WASTE OF CANCER
MEDICATION THAT IS OCCURRING.
AND THIS- ITEM ADDRESSES THAT
THAT CONCERNED ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT THERE IS A NEED FOR SOME
STATUTORY CHANGES. THAT WOULD
BENEFIT THE TYPE OF VOLUNTARY
DRUG REPOSITORY DISTRIBUTION
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE USE FOR
OTHER MEDICATIONS COULD YOU
SPEAK TO THAT. I'M SORRY SO- IS
SPECIFIC TO THE DAY- CANCER
MEDICATION- THERE IS A PROGRAM
WITHIN THE LAW THAT ALLOWS FOR
THE REDISTRIBUTION OF
MEDICATIONS THERE IS NO
PROHIBITION ON AND I CANCER
MEDICATIONS THE DRUGS THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE- BY AND LARGE ARE-
DEVELOPED BY THE COUNTY PROGRAM
WHICH ON. I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY
COUNTY THAT IS CURRENTLY
INCLUDING CANCER BUT I DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE ANY
PROHIBITIONS IN THE LAW THAT
WOULD PREVENT THEM FROM DOING
SO. VERY GOOD WILL WE WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR CONTINUED
EXAMINATION OF THAT TO SEE
WHETHER OR NOT THERE WOULD BE
ANY LIMITATIONS THAT WOULD NOT
ALLOW. FOR THE VOLUNTARY-
DISTRIBUTION OF SUCH LIFESAVING
MEDICATION I'D LIKE TO CLOSE MY
QUESTIONS BY INVITING MR LIPPY
TO COME BACK. TO THE SCREEN
MISTER THAT BE THAT PER SHAPE-THE AGAIN THE GOOD WORK THAT
YOU AND THE BOARD DO YOU ARE
INVOLUNTARY POSITIONS BUT YOU
AREIN POSITIONS OF LEADERSHIP.
AND A PART OF THAT IS THAT NEED
IN THE REQUIREMENT TO ENGAGE IN
AND MANY OF THESE SERIOUS
ISSUES SOME OF WHICH WE'VE
DISCUSSED HERE TODAY- I
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP IN-
ENSURING THAT THE BOARD HAS THE
TIME TO DELIBERATE AND ENGAGE.
WE WANTYOUR EXPERTISE TO COME
IN WITH GREAT- DIVERSITY AND
EXPERTISE IN THESE IN THESE
MATTERS WE WANT TO TAKE THAT
INTO ACCOUNT BUT IT DOES
REQUIRE THE BOARD TO BE
ENGAGED. AND NOT TO BE AFRAID
TO TAKE ON CHALLENGING ISSUES
DIFFICULT ISSUES WITH THERE'S
CONFLICTS. BECAUSE WE WANT YOUR
EXPERTISE IN THE GAME WE WANT
YOUR INPUT AND I WOULD SUGGEST
THANK YOU AGAIN AND GIVE YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY CLOSE HERE AT
LEAST IN THIS SEGMENT BEFORE WE
GO TO. PUBLIC TESTIMONY. ABOUT
AT THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING
TO GET THE BOARDING GAUGED. ON
THESE MATTERS SOME OF WHICH
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT TODAY. OKAY
WHAT WE'RE DOING MOSTLY- IS.
CONTINUING TO HAVE MANY MANY
MEETINGS ABOUT THE DIFFERENT
ISSUES- LATELY IT HASN'T AS I
MENTIONED IN MY OPENING
REMARKS. MOST OF OUR TIME IS
BEING SPENT MOST OF MY TIME HAS
BEEN SPENT IN ISSUING APPROVING
WAIVERS. RELATED TO THE
PANDEMIC I UNDERSTAND THAT ALL
THESE OTHER ISSUES AND
NECESSARY ESPECIALLY ON THE
ENFORCEMENT AREA- I DON'T KNOW
IF IT'S BEEN MENTIONED HERE IN
THE PAST BUT- WE DEAL WITH
APPROXIMATELY- FIFTY OR SIXTY
CASES A MONTH. ON THE
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS SO IT'S A
VERY ACTIVE BOARD- WE DON'T
TAKE THIS LIGHTLY. AND- WE
EXPECT THAT TO GO THROUGH ALL
OF YOUR ISSUES AND MAKE SURE
THAT THE BOARD TAKES
LEADERSHIP. IN THE RESPONSE TO
A- THANK YOU MR LIBBY WE LOOK
WE THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND WE CERTAINLY
WANT TO ENCOURAGE IS- VIGOROUS
ENERGY AND ENGAGEMENT GOT GOING
FORWARD. ALL RIGHT I'M GONNA
ASK MEMBERS ONE LAST TIME IF
THERE'S FURTHER QUESTIONS I SEE
SENATOR AN HERE IN THE CHAMBER
AND THEN I'LL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. AND SEE IF THERE'S
MEMBERS OUT IN THE- WORLD OUT
THERE THAT ALSO THE FOLLOWING
QUESTIONS TO ASK BUT SENATOR
CAN'T PLEASE THANK YOU JUST A
ONE BRIEF QUESTION ABOUT ISSUE
NUMBER SIX WHICH IS FISCAL
ISSUES REGARDING THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL BILLING RATE- AND I
KNOW THERE'S A BROADER ISSUE
JUST THE BOARD OF PHARMACY-
BUT- IN REGARDS TO THE BOARD
ITSELF- AND I KNOW THAT SOME OF
THIS IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY
BECAUSE WE PASS. BUDGETS- FOR
THE STATE. WHAT HOW MUCH DONE
NOTIFICATION OR JUSTIFICATION.
HEAD WAS PROVIDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE TO THE-
BOARD OF PHARMACY. FOR THE RATE
INCREASES THAT THEY CHARGE
BECAUSE IT IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT RATE INCREASE. FOR
LEGAL SERVICES. SO I'LL SPEAK
IN GENERAL TERMS BUT- WITH
YOUR- APPROVAL WOULD LIKE TO
RESPOND TO THAT MORE FULLY WHEN
THE BOARD SUBMITS ITS RESPONSES
TO THESE ISSUES IN GENERAL-
SOME OF THE NOTIFICATION WAS-
THAT THROUGH THAT DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS- AND SOME
DIRECTLY- I WOULD SAY THAT IT
IT WAS HARD TO- MANAGE AND
NAVIGATE THE INCREASE WE
BELIEVE THAT. WERE OKAY FOR
NOW- BUT WITH DAY THE STATE NOT
BE SEEN- THE BUDGET CRISIS THAT
IT IS FOR GOING TO HAVE TO LOOK
AT OUR BUDGET INITS ENTIRETY-
NOT JUST THE EIGHTEEN LINE ITEM
BUT THOSE KINDS OF UNEXPECTED-
EXPENSES- DO YOU CREATE- SOME
CHALLENGES OPERATIONALLY AND
BUT WE WORK HARD TO TRY TO-
NAVIGATE AND MITIGATE. RIGHT
THANK YOU- IT YES CERTAINLY
DIED ANY SORT OF FEEDBACK WE
CAN GET FROM BOARDS- AS WE DO
OUR OWN BUDGET DELIBERATIONS
AND- I OUR OWN CONVERSATIONS
WITH DEPARTMENT JUSTICE IS
GOING TO BE HELPFUL. THERE'S A
SOMEONE WHO HOLDS A LICENSE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
PHARMACY BUT ANOTHER BOARD- YOU
KNOW THIS TRICKLES DOWN SO WHAT
HAPPENS IS THAT YOU GET HIT
WITH THIS P. AND THEN THE YOU
HAVE TO RAISE YOUR FEES WHICH
THEN HITS. THOSE OF US ON THE
FRONT LINES TRYING TO TAKE YOUR
PATIENCE SOME OF US- WE THERE'S
AN ARTICLE ABOUT HOW PHYSICIAN
FOR PHARMACIES
BEEN STRESSES AND STRAINS AS
WELL FINANCIALLY FOR MANY
PHARMACIES PHARMACISTS- AND WE
NEED TO BE MORE SENSITIVE TO
THAT ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU HAVE
VERY RAPID INCREASES OR CHANGES
AND FEES. AS A RESULT AND AT
LEAST OUR NEEDS WE NEED TO SEEK
OUT SOME JUSTIFICATION AS TO
WHY THE SUDDEN CHANGES THAT AND
HAVE THESE DOWNSTREAM EFFECTS
THAT BEGAN AFFECTING THOSE
OPTING TO OPERATIONS A BUDGET
THE BOARD AND THEN OF COURSE
THE LICENSEES WHO. MAY HAVE TO
DENDERA SEE INCREASED HELP
SUPPORT THE VERY IMPORTANT
FUNCTIONS OF. THE BOARD SO
THANK YOU AND I LOOK FOR TO
THAT MORE THE- THAT PRESS-
ANSWER- WHEN YOU- THE BOY
RESPOND. IN WRITING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR CHAIR LOW.
FIGURE MUCH CHAIR GLACIER. I
JUST WONDER YEAR AND OF CAN
WITH SOME THE THAT BEEN POSED
BY THE RESPECTIVE INCOME MEMBER.
A SPECIAL TO THE DIRECTOR MR
GRIN OF. THE BOARD RECEIVED A
NUMBER OF THESE QUESTIONS
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT MONTHS AGO.
TO WHICH AS WE ALL KNOW THIS
HEARING WAS DEFERRED TO THIS
DATE. AND SO IN THEORY THE
BOARD HAS HAD UP TO EIGHT
MONTHS TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE PROVIDED IN
ADVANCE AND THUS FAR IT'S BEEN
MY OBSERVATION THAT THE- BOARD
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR HAS BEEN
SOMEWHAT EVASIVE AND NOT
ANSWERING DIRECTLY THESE
QUESTIONS AND I HAVE SOME
CONCERNS I JUST WANT TO. SHARE
THOSE OBSERVATIONS THAT MOVING
FORWARD I HOPE THAT YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO HAVE DEFINITIVE ANSWERS
I HEARD A LOT OF EVASION WITH
RESPECT TO THE BOARD NOT TAKING
A POSITION QUITE YET- BUT
CERTAINLY GIVEN THE LONG LENGTH
OF TIME TO WHICH THE BOARD HAS
HAD. SOME OF THESE ISSUES. TO
BE ADDRESSED I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE EXERCISE OUR
OVERSIGHT CAPACITY AND HOLD THE
BOARD TO ACCOUNT SO AGAIN.
PLEASE INTERPRET THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ON THE
pEXPECT TO HAVE SPECIFIC DIRECT
ANSWERS TO THESE QUESTIONS. AND
WE FEEL THAT THERE'S BEEN AN
ABUNDANCE OF TIME ALLOTTED TO
ADDRESSING THESE IN ADVANCE SO.
AGAIN WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT WE
CAN PARTNER WITH YOU TO
CONTINUE TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE. THE DIRECT ANSWERS IN
ADDRESSING THE SPECIFIC
OUTLINING ISSUES SO THAT WE CAN
ADDRESS THE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AND MAKING SURE
THAT THIS WORKS FOR EVERYONE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. WELL SAID. LOW THAT TIME
LINE I THINK IS ACCURATE.
THERE'S A SENSITIVITY TO FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION INTO THE
SUNSET REVIEW PROCESSES AND IN
THE PAST THERE'S BEEN SOME.
CRITICISM THAT THEY HAD NOT HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE IN
THESE TYPES OF DISCUSSIONS- AN
APPROPRIATE WAY AND I WOULD
NOTE THAT- WE DON'T WANT TO
HAVE THOSE DISAGREEMENTS WE
WANT TO FIND COMMON GROUND. AND
WE- THAT THAT'S BEST DONE BY A
FULL ENGAGE PROCESS FROM THE
BEGINNING. AND THAT'S OF COURSE
WHAT WE'RE CONTINUING HERE
TODAY AND WE HOPE TO CONTINUE-
IN THE WEEKS AHEAD BUT WE DON'T
WANT IT TO BE DELAYED WE WANT
TO GET TO THESE ISSUES WE WANT
TO. HAVE YOUR EXPERTISE AND
YOUR THOUGHTFULNESS SO THAT WE
CAN DO OUR BEST WORK I THINK
YOU'RE A LITTLE FOR.
REITERATING THAT OKAY I DON'T
SEE ANY HANDS UP FROM OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE HERE IN
THE CHAMBER SO WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO- PEOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC TESTIMONY. ON
THIS BOARD OF PHARMACY REVIEW
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY-
I WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY I DON'T
SEE ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY
I'M GONNA GO TO. ROOM ONE
TWELVE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. I
DON'T SEE ANY PRESENT THERE SO
WE'RE GOING TO PROVIDE- TO
WE'RE GONNA GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS. MODERATOR I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN PATIENT ON THE LINE AS
HAVE OTHERS. WOULD YOU PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC TESTIMONY ON
AGENDA ITEM ONE THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY. SO WE COULD HEAR
THEIR TESTIMONY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IF YOU DO WISH TO
SHARE PUBLIC COMMENT ON AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER ONE. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. THEY GET THE
IT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE'LL
GO FIRST ONLINE FIFTEEN ONE
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS SUSAN BONE YEAH CEO OF
THE CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION. I WANTED TO THANK
TEACHER LOCHER GLAZER MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND ALSO
RECOGNIZED- THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY DCA AND SECRETARY
CASTRO RAMIREZ WE I HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOUIN THE CAR CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION. MY
COMING TO GET THEIR DEFENSE
SUPPORT OF MOVING TOWARDS A
STANDARD OF CARE MODEL FOR THE
PRACTICE OF PHARMACY I
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE ALSO FOCUSED
ON. MAKING SURE THAT EMAIL OUR-
MANDATORILY COLLECTED AND
AVAILABLE. PARTICULARLY IN
TIMES OF CRISIS. WE ALSO BUT
THAT HAVING A- BERMAN ON THE
BOARD GREAT ASSIST IN- CONSUMER
PROTECT AND THE PUNK OF THE-
AND WE ARE ALSO- PUT ON AN
ALTERNATE DIGITAL PROCESS AND
HAVE BEEN WORKING PRODUCTIVELY
WITH THE BOARD ON THIS ISSUE.
WANTED TO SHARE TODAY THAT
COVER NINETEEN HAS SHOT A
BRIGHT LIGHT ON THE FRAGILE
NATURE OF OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. HAS POCKETS TO
REEVALUATE OUR PREPARATION SO
THAT WE CAN ADEQUATELY CARE FOR
CALIFORNIANS- WE REALLY I DID
RUN INTO A NUMBER OF YEARS WITH
THE COMPANY CRAZINESS. THAT WE
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE BOARD BUT
THERE WERE MONTH DELAYS- SIMPLY
ALLOW CORPSMAN TO DO SETTLEMENT
COLLECTIONS I TOOK ABOUT. THEN
YOU DO AND CAN THINK TOOK
ANOTHER OF. YEAH WE HAD TO WAIT
PROCESS BUT- I THINK GREAT
IMPROVE COULD BE MADE IN THAT
PROCESS SO THAT PATIENTS.
RECEIVE AND PREVENT ACCESS
COULD BE INCREASED IT WAS
CUMBERSOME. WE BELIEVE THAT- WE
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS ARE
ABLE TO WORK COLLABORATIVELY
WITH THE BOARD TOWARD THE
CANADA CARE MODEL. THAT WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO REMOVE SOME OF
THE REGULATORY BURDEN AND
BETTER SERVE AND CREATE BETTER
ACCESS FOR PATIENTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND ULTIMATELY
BETTER HERE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR CONSIDERING OUR ISSUES
TODAY WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING A PRODUCTIVE THREE YEARS
BETWEEN THIS. REVIEW AND THE
NEXT ONE WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT
THE PROFESSION- CAN MOVE
TOWARDS THE TOP OF IT LICENSING
AND THAT THE STANDARD OF CARE
MODEL THAT IS USED. TO REGULATE
OTHER HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS.
SHOULD BE USED FOR PHARMACISTS
AS WELL- YOU KNOW THAT THE
MULTI YEAR PROCESS- WE KNOW
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A LOT OF
WORK IN COLLABORATION BUT WE
ARE VERY HOPEFUL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL BE THAT THIS.
FALL SOME OF THE PROBLEMS THAT
SURFACED DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND THAT ULTIMATELY WILL FOLLOW
PATIENT ACTORS. AND ALSO. LAKE
STREET. LATEST AND AFFORDABLE
HEALTH CARE MODEL BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT PHARMACY AND THEIR-
MANAGE. FUNCTION WILL BE ABLE
TO- PROVIDE THAT. CARE ALLOWS
HEALTH TO TRUE BE A PART OF.
THANK YOU SO FOR A MY COM. AND
WE APPRECIATED ALL THOSE THAT
CLUB AND MORE WITH THE THIRD
PATIENT HOW. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- THIS FOR THOUGHT
FOR COMMENTS AND THE CA. AND
THE STAFF WILL HAVE HEARD THE
THEN WILL TAKE THE MEDICAID.
AND WE THEM- MODERATOR I WILL
TO GO TO THE CALLER BUT YOU
TELL ME MANY FOLKS HAVING WHO
WOULD TO PROVIDE. JUST ONE LINE
AT THIS TIME. VERY GOOD IF YOU
COULD INVITE THAT PERSON TO- TO
COME FORWARD APPRECIATED. THANK
YOU LINE FOURTEEN ONE FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I CAN'T REMEMBER
MINING IS DADDY GRANDMA AND I'M
A LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH
UFCW WORKERS TOWN CALLED
APPEARING BRIEFLY ON BEHALF OF
OUR THOUSANDS PHARMACISTS AND
PHARMACY TECHNICIAN MEMBERS
WORKING AT COMMUNITY PHARMACY.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. I LIKE
TO THINK THEY CAN CARE AND
MEMBERS AND THE BOARD OF. I AND
THEIR STAFF FOR PREPARING CAN I
PLAY BACKGROUND PAPER WOULD
LIKE OFFER BRIEFED ON S. REYES.
IN THE PAPER. FIND LOOK AT THE
BOARD THE NEW SOME OF THE
WORLD'S LARGEST. TRADED THREE.
FROM ENGAGE AND I'M- TAKING
INTEGRITY KERR BUT OUR PARKING
LOT THE THIRD AS KIND OF
DETERRENT AROUND. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WITH THE- AND THE
COMMITTEE. I'M HAPPY YOU CALLED
WHOLE CRPET ACCOUNT. FOR
CORPORATE POLICIES HARMS. CARE
SECOND CREATING A NEW. PHARMACY
MIGHT PLAN. MEANS THAT DOG.
THAT USED TO BE. BY PHARMACY.
WILL NOW GO TO THE WHO CAN
AFFORD THE KIND AND COST OF
MORE TRAIN. AND ADVANCED BY
TECH. MY GREAT THE- BARRIERS
THAT. WITH THIS APARTMENT HARM
LOW INCOME WORKERS. PEOPLE OF
COLOR SINGLE. THIRDS THE STATE
WE EXPANDED FROM ITS- BUT
PRACTICAL THE- OF BACK.
CURRENTLY THERE CURRENTLY
EFFECT BERMAN. WHO ARE WILLING
ABLE TO PERFORM SERVICE AS AND
EAGER TO. THE PROGRAM BACK
BEING ONE MADE OF THE- HOWEVER.
PHARMACIES THAT MEASURE BACKED
IT PRETTY MUCH. THE FACT WILL
NEED TO BE. BY FINALLY SAYS
ADDING IN A- THREE PROVIDE ROLE
THROUGH THE ARE READY. LET THAN
THIRTY. TRYING TO PERFORM THIS
IS A FOR DRAIN ON THE PAR.
ALREADY HI. RESPECTFULLY PIECE
AND BY PRO STAFF SAID AND-
BEFORE WE KNEW THAT SOUND A
SMALL. IN PHARMACY STAFFING THE
EIGHTIES. WE RESPECTFULLY. A
CONCRETE. ANKLE WORK IN OUR-
SHOULD BE DONE FOR A LARGE
EMPLOYER. OR THE PRESSURE THAT
THE GREATEST. THAT ALL WE
FORWARD TO WORK WITH ITS
COMMITTEES THE BOARD AND
STAKEHOLDERS SUCH A EFFORT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY FOR
YOUR TO. HI MY IS THERE ANYBODY
ELSE WHO IS TO PROVIDE TEST ON
THE BOARD OF PHARMACY. WE DO
HAVE A TO LINE QF TIME IN LIGHT
AND- TO SPEAK WITH WE WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU. BY
NINETEEN ONE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
INVOLVED AROUND WITH THE WAY TO
MY GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE K.
SYSTEM OF HEALTH FOR. WE
REPRESENT OF PROFESSIONALS
PROFESSIONALS ACROSS- WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE WORK THAT THE
BOARD OF. IT DOWN DURING
PANDEMIC TO ALLOW PHARMACISTS
TO BE AT THE FOREFRONT OF
CALIFORNIANS PANDEMIC RESPONSE.
AND COULD CONTINUE IN THAT ROLE
AS WE MOVE CLOSER TOWARD
DISTRIBUTING THE VACCINE. WE
AGREE WITH THE COMMONSENSE G.
P. AJ THAT THINGS COULD BE
MOVING QUICKER AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO WORK ON HOW WE CAN
IMPROVE RESPONSE. THAT WE FEEL
OVERALL THAT THEIR ATTENTION TO
THE NEEDS OF CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA. HAS BEEN GOOD- IT
HAS NOT JUST BEEN THOUGHTFUL
BUT THEY'VE BEEN RESPONSIVE TO
MEETING THE NEEDS. OF OUR
PROFESSION AND PHARMACY
TECHNICIANS- AS WE ALL WORK TO
COMBAT THIS. EPIDEMIC WE ALSO
WANT TO THANK SENATOR PAN FOR
HIS THOUGHTFUL QUESTIONS AND
FOR HIS RECOGNITION OF THE ROLE
PHARMACISTS CAN PLAY. I THINK
SCREENING COMMITTEE MANAGEMENT
COPING BACKING. AS WELL AS
OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE
EFFORTS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING ON THAT IN THE COMING
YEAR- ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITHTHE BOARD IN YOUR
RESPECTIVE COMMITTEES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE QUESTION TODAY
WERE ALL ADDRESSED
APPROPRIATELY AND SO THAT THE
BOARD TO CONTINUE TO DELIVER
THE HIGHEST STANDARD OF CARE AT
ALL CALIFORNIANS. WE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF THE TIME. I THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY OPERATOR WOULD
YOU CHECK AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANYBODY ELSE THAT'S ON THE LINE
THAT WISHES TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN THE PORT OF
PHARMACY. ANYONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT TO
ME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. HI AT LAST AT LAST
CALL FINAL TIME OPERATOR. THERE
ARE NO MIND N Q. GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT I'M
GONNA WE'RE GONNA CLOSE DECIDED
THAT I WANTED TO CHECK ONE LAST
TIME WITH MEMBERS HERE ON THE
FLOOR OR- CONNECTING WITH US
REMOTELY WHEN THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. I DON'T
SEE ANY HANDS UP SO WE'RE GONNA
THANK- MR LIBBY THAT THANK
GOODNESS SO THE GRAND FOR-
PROVIDING YOUR- RESPONSE AND
BACKGROUND INFORMATION TO OUR
QUESTIONS TODAY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU IN
THE WEEKS AHEAD- AND-
FINALIZING ALL THE MATTERS
REGARDING. TO SUNSET REVIEW OF
YOUR- BOARDS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OKAY. WE'RE GONNA MOVE NOW
TO AGENDA ITEM NUMBER TWO. THIS
IS THE REVIEW OF THE PODIA
TRICK MEDICAL BOARD OF.
CALIFORNIA ONE OF OUR MIND-
EIGHTY WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
PROVIDE. TESTIMONY ON THE SIDE
OF THE PLEASE CALL IN NOW SO WE
CAN MAKE SURE THAT YOU ARE IN
QUEUE- I'D LIKE TO- INVITES-
PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD DR JUDY
MANZI THE BOARD EXECUTIVE
OFFICER BRIAN ASSELIN. AND I
BELIEVE THERE LEGISLATIVE
COORDINATOR IS ALSO AVAILABLE
KATHLEEN COOPER. TO- KENEXA THE
R. ZOOM HERE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR TESTIMONY. WE
WERE BEGINNING WITH THAT DOCTOR
NANCY IS THAT RIGHT. CORRECT
THANK YOU. MMHM GOOD MORNING TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
IN THE ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE I'M
DOCTOR JUDY MANZI THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT OF THE CODE YOU
ENTERED MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA AND AS YOU SAID WITH
ME TODAY IS BRIAN ASSELIN OUR
EXECUTIVE OFFICER KATHLEEN
COOPER ADMINISTRATION ANALYST
BETHANY DEANGELIS ARE FORCING
COORDINATOR AND I'M TRADING IN
OUR LICENSING COORDINATOR AND
BEFORE I START I JUST WANT TO
PRAISE THEM AND THANK THEM FOR
THEIR DILIGENCE AND COMPLEMENT
THEIR HARD WORK. IN TIMES OF
KOBE OUR OFFICE IS MANAGED TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE- OUR MEMBERS
AND. OUR- LICENSEES. ON BEHALF
THE LICENSE THE MEMBER OF STAFF
ANALYST STAKEHOLDERS A KODIAQ.
MEDICAL BOARD COUNCIL. IS MY
PLEASURE TO PRESENT HIGHLIGHTS
THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS SINCE THE
LAST SUNSET REVIEW WHICH IS IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. HOW DO
ACTIVE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA AND OTHER
HEALTH CARE BOARDS WITH IN DCA.
THE BUSINESS'S PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEES
AND THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY.
INDIVIDUAL SENATORS AND
ASSEMBLY PERSONS AS WELL AS
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS RELATED TO
THE PODIUM TO MEDICAL
PROFESSION CALIFORNIA WHICH HAS
RESULTED IN IMPROVED
EFFICIENCIES AND COST
CONSCIOUSNESS. AS FAR AS OUR
FIRST WILL. ADDRESS OUR
LEGISLATIVE ACCOMPLISHMENTS SB
SEVEN NINETY EIGHT CREATED
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THE KODIAQ
CARE MEDICAL BOARDING
CALIFORNIA'S RELATIONSHIP TO
THE MEDICAL BOARD CALIFORNIA.
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IS
THAT THAT THEIR CERTIFICATES
ARE NOT ISSUED AND SIGNED BY
THE CODE YOU ENTERED MEDICAL
BOARD CALIFORNIA'S BOARD
PRESIDENT AND NOT THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
PRESIDENT. THAT PUT AMERICAN OF
CALIFORNIA REQUESTED AND
RECEIVED A TITLE CHANGE
PURSUANT TO AB TWO FOUR FIVE
SEVEN WHICH BECAME EFFECTIVE
JULY TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
THIS PROVIDES FOR A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE FUNCTIONS
OF THE BOARD'S LICENSEES AS
DOCTORS AND SURGEONS OFFERING
ALLOPATHIC MEDICAL AND SURGICAL
TREATMENT OF THE FOOT AND ANKLE.
AND LASTLY THE KODIAQ MEDICAL
DOCTORS CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
OUTSTANDING CARE TO OVER FOUR
MILLION CALIFORNIANS. ARE
SUFFERING WITH DIABETES SAVING
LIVES IS ONE OF THE MORE
NOTABLE THINGS THE PROFESSION
DOES FAST. EVERY DAY PODIATRIST
CALLED UPON TO HELP PREVENT
WOUNDS PROVIDING CARE INFORM
SURGICAL LIMB SALVAGE
PROCEDURES WHEN NEEDED. THAT
BEING RECOGNIZE THE PROFESSION
WAS ABLE TO OBTAIN A SCHOOL
INCREASE THROUGH AB ONE ONE
FIVE THREE. THIS ACTUALLY
EXPANDED THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE
TO THE LICENSEES ALONG
PROACTIVE MEDICAL DOCTORS
TRAINED AND EXPERIENCED IN
WOUND CARE AND SURGICAL LIMB
SALVAGE TO TREAT ULCERS BIGELOW
RIDICULE TO RECALL WHICH. IS
ESSENTIALLY TO THE- IN REGARDS
OUR ADMIN ACCOMPLISHMENTS I
ONCE AGAIN CANNOT COMPLEMENT
OUR EXECUTIVE OFFICER IN OUR
STOP ENOUGH HERE AND WITH OUR
BOARD WAS ABLE TO UPDATE THEIR
TECHNOLOGY RESULTING IN COST
SAVINGS AND EFFICIENCIES ARE
PROCURING A MULTI FUNCTIONAL
DEVICE WHICH ALLOWS IN HOUSE
PROCESSING. ABOARD MATERIALS
OUT REACHING TALES AND OTHER
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATIONS WHICH
ALLOCATES TO A COST SAVINGS
MEASURE. ADDITIONALLY ETTRICK
MINIMUM OF CALIFORNIA WAS
GRANTED A TEMPORARY FEE
INCREASE OF TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER BI ANNUAL RENEWAL WHICH IS
EFFECTIVE JANUARY TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. AND AUTOMATICALLY
TERMINATES AT THE END OF
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY THIS
GAVE THE PODIUM TECH MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA THE
FLEXIBILITY TO CONDUCT A FEW
STUDY AND MEET ITS OBLIGATION
TO MAINTAIN A VIABLE CONDITION
TO ACHIEVE CONSUMER PROTECTION
THREE TWENTY TWENTY. OVER THE
PAST FOUR YEARS THE PODIUM AND
MEDICAL BOARD CALIFORNIA HAS
INCREASED FOCUS ON OUTREACH BY
REINSTATING ITS BI ANNUAL
NEWSLETTER FOOTNOTES IT
REGULARLY UPDATES ITS WEBSITE
AND SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTS AND
SENDING DIRECT COMMUNICATIONS
TO STAKEHOLDERS. WHO ARE
REGISTERED FOR A LISTS ARE ALSO
THE LAST FOUR YEARS ALL BOARD
MEETINGS HAVE BEEN BROADCAST
AND ARCHIVED ON OUR WEBSITE AND
UPLOAD TO YOUTUBE PROVIDING
DETAILED INFORMATION TO HIS
VIEWERS. THE PODIA ETTRICK
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
HIRED BRIAN ASSELIN AS THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICE OF THE PODIA
ETTRICK MEDICAL BOARD
CALIFORNIA IN THE FALL OF TWO
THOUSAND SIXTY. MISTER NAZARIAN
IS AN OUTSTANDING CHOICE HE
CAME TO THE BOARD WITH OVER
TWENTY YEARS OF MANAGEMENT AND
FOR SOME EXPERIENCE IN STATE
SERVICE HE SERVES ON BOARDS
WITH A FOCUS IN INTELLIGENCE
AND BRINGS A LEVEL OF EXPERTISE
AND KNOWLEDGE. THAT HAS HELPED
US TREMENDOUSLY OVER THE PAST
FOUR YEARS. INTO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE PARTY AFTER
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
TRAINING AND DEVELOPMENT
FACILITATORS SOLID. AND ALL
BOARD MEMBERS AND STAFF TO
CREATE THE 200-019-2020 TWO
STRATEGIC PLANS. THIS INCLUDED
AN ACTUAL PLAN FOR TRACKING IN
ACHIEVING GOALS STATED WITHIN
THE STRATEGIC PLAN.
ADDITIONALLY THE BOARD'S POLICY
MANUALS UPDATED IN CURRENT USE.
SINCE THE LAST SUNSET THE PODIA
ETTRICK MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIORNIA LICENSING PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTED ONLINE LICENSE
RENEWALS AND INITIAL
APPLICATIONS WHICH ALLOWS THE
LICENSEES AND THE APPLICANTS
THE CONVENIENCE AND EXPEDIENCY
OF MAKING IMMEDIATE PAYMENTS
THROUGH BREEZE AND THE OPTION
TO PAY WITH A CREDIT CARD WHICH
PREVIOUSLY NOT AVAILABLE.
ADDITIONALLY THE LICENSING
PROGRAM HAS CONSISTENTLY
PERFORMED ANNUAL CMT ARTISTS TO
VERIFY LICENSEES ARE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH OUR CME
REQUIREMENTS. SOURCE MICRO WAS
ABLE TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS TO
ITS CONSULTANTS AND EXPERT
PROGRAM BY UPDATING ITS
TRAINING MATERIALS CREATING AN
ONLINE TUTORIAL IN
COLLABORATION WITH SOLID IN
HOLDING THREE IN PERSON
CONSULTING TRAINING SINCE THE
LAST SUNSET. ADDITIONALLY
UPDATED CONSULTED AN EXPERT
EVALUATION FORMS WERE PROVIDED
TO THE DIVISION OF
INVESTIGATION IN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE TO MONITOR THE
PERFORMANCE OF OUR CONTRACTED
CONSULTANTS AND EXPERTS IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE FEEDBACK OR
ADDITIONAL TRAINING WHEN
NECESSARY. RECENTLY WITH THE
ACTIVATION OF ONLINE PAYMENTS
AND THE ABILITY TO PAY WITH A
CREDIT CARD RECEIPT LICENSEES
WITH COST RECOVERY OR OTHER
IMPORTANT COST MAKING PAYMENTS
IN FULL INSTEAD OF USING A
PAYMENT PLAN. IN SUMMARY THE
PUBLIC RECORD CALIFORNIA HAS
PROVIDED THESE COMMITTEES WITH
AT SUNSET. YOUR REPORT TO THIS
HEARING WE ARE PREPARED TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND WE
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR NANCY. MR AZLAN
DID YOU HAVE ANYTHING YOU
WANTED TO ADD O THAT THE
TESTIMONY BEFORE WE OPEN IT UP
FOR QUESTIONS. BUT NO I THINK
I'M GOOD AT THE DOCTOR MEANS HE
COVERED EVERYTHING I WAS GOING
TO COVER- ON HERE AND WE CAN
JUST GO RIGHT TO YOUR- QUESTION
CAN ISSUES SCHOOL. VERY GOOD
I'D LIKE TO INVITE- COLLEAGUES
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS AND ON OUR
PHONE LINES IF THEY HAVE
QUESTIONS TO PLEASE SO INDICATE
SO WE COULD US. CALLING YOU I
SEE SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU-
SERRA GLACIER A TRANSLATOR AND
AGAIN CREATE THE PRESENTATION
FROM THE- FOR THE ACTOR THE
MEDICAL BOARD- I DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS- ACTUALLY QUESTIONS I
ASK OF- PARTICULARLY THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONS BOARD- RELATE TO
CONTINUING EDUCATION I WOULD
MAKE NOTE THAT. ACCORDING TO
YOUR REPORT- THAT LOOKS LIKE
YOU- BASICALLY AUDIT ABOUT 5%
OF YOUR LICENSEES UNDER
ELECTION UNDER RENEWAL CYCLES.
AND CERTAINLY SHOWING THAT YOU
HAVE A- LOW- FAILURE RATE ON
THE- C. I. IT'S- SO PERHAPS YOU
CAN COMMENT JUST BRIEFLY FIRST
OF ALL ON THE YET THAT THIS. IS
THERE ANY CHANGE IN THE AUDIT
RATES- GOING FORWARD SO YOU WE
TALKED ABOUT THE LAST FOUR
YEARS BUT- LITTERED IN TERMS OF
YOUR OWN STAFFING. AND THEN THE
SECOND QUESTION RELATED TO
CONTINUE EDUCATION IS THAT MAKE
NOTE THAT THE BOARD ITSELF
ACTUALLY APPROVES- THE
CONSUMING EDUCATION PROVIDERS
AN ORGANIZATION INSTITUTIONS.
AND WHILE YOU MAKE NOTE THAT
YOU DON'T ACTIVELY AUDIT TO SEE
PROVIDERS THAT YOU DO HAVE A
POLICY BUT TO WHAT DEGREE DO
YOU- ACTUALLY CONDUCT ANY
REVIEW ARMED FORCE MEANT OF THE
C. E. TO ENSURE THAT MEET
STANDARDS AND THEN FINALLY- DO
YOU HAVE A CONFLICT OF INTEREST
STANDARD TO ENSURE THAT THE C.
E- PEOPLE THE LICENSEES ARE
RECEIVING IS. ACTUALLY
CONTINUING EDUCATION AND NOT
MARKETING- FROM- INTERESTED-
INDUSTRIES ARE ARE ARE PROVIDE
OUR- THE COMPANY'S SIDE SO THAT
THERE'S A CONFLICT OF INTEREST
POLICY TEACHER THE C. IS
SEPARATE FROM. A SEPARATE FROM-
UNDUE COMMERCIAL INFLUENCE SO-
THOSE ARE THREE QUESTIONS
RELATE TO CONTINUE EDUCATION
AND IF YOU COULD PLEASE ADDRESS
THOSE. ZERO THREE- SO THE SCENE
EACH YEAR WE- USUALLY DO OUR
AUDITS- WANTED TIMES A YEAR.
AND WE HAVE A VERY LOW RATE OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT COMPLIANCE
WE DO HAVE BEEN REGULATIONS
WAIVER REQUIREMENT. THAT
SPECIALLY DURING CODE RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE ONE PERSON SOME THAT
WAIVER REQUEST HERE AND- WE
DIDN'T NEED TO GET PAID- A
WAIVER OUTSIDE. BECAUSE WE
ALREADY HAVE THE REGULATIONS
ONE PERSON WAS UNABLE TO
COMPLETE THEIR. SEEN THESE
BECAUSE THE- SOURCE THAT THERE
WILL BE TO TAKE RISKS. ON IN
YOUR SECOND QUESTION AGAIN WELL
I GUESS AND OF THE FOR QUESTION
IS LESS THAT BECAUSE HE DID
PROVIDERS. IN TERMS OF RATE
PERCENTAGE YOU PLAN TO AUDIT IS
THAT GOING TO CHANGE IN THE
UPCOMING YEARS OR IS THAT- USED
IS THAT PATTERN STILL GOING TO
STAY THE SAME LOOKS LIKE YOU
ARE APPROXIMATE 5% OF YOUR
LICENSEES. TO USE THAT SELLERS
PROBABLY GONNA BE THE SAME OKAY
IT LOOKS LIKE THE PATTERNS OF
SAYING IT SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE
ALL. THREE HALF YEARS IT LOOKS
THE IN BACK IN HIS DATA ON THAT
LOOKS LIKE IT THAT FOR STAY
THIS OKAY AND THE SECOND THE
SECOND QUESTION WAS ABOUT
BECAUSE THE BOARD ITSELF
ACTUALLY PROVES COMMUNICATION
COURSE PROVIDERS AND WORK THESE
INSTITUTIONS. AND MAKE NOTE
THAT IN YOUR REPORT YOU SAID
THAT YOU DON'T ACTIVELY AUDIT
THESE PROVIDERS WHAT TYPE OF A
REVIEW OR ENFORCEMENT DO YOU DO
OF THE CONTINUING EDUCATION TO
BE CERTAIN STANDARDS AND THEN
FINALLY YOU HAVE A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST POLICY TO ENSURE
THERE'S AN UNDUE COMMERCIAL
INFLUENCE OVER THE CONTINUED
EDUCATION CONTENT. THAT
PROVIDERS ARE. RECEIVING
THROUGH CONTINUING EDUCATION.
RIGHT SO SEEK IS BEING
GOVERNING OVER THE SEA AND USE
HERE ON THERE IS A ONE ON THE
WEBSITE ONCE YOU CAN BE WEBSITE
OF APPROVED SCHEME EQUAL. IN SO
WE USE THAT GUIDANCE- TO-
PRODUCT WHAT AVAILABLE SEE N.
B. COURSE OR OR ON MORE TO THE.
I ALSO LIKE TO ADD. IN IF I MAY
PLEASE. YES SO THAT'S A GOOD
POINT THE C. P. THERE IS WELL
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO GET A
LICENSE CALIFORNIA IT'S
PROBABLY OF MORE MOST DIFFERENT
STATE. IN THE KIND TO GET
LICENSES A PODIATRIST. WITH
THAT BEING SAID CPM WE YOU PAY
DUES TO BOTH TO. ME YOU
INCLUDED IN THAT IS. A SEMINAR
THAT'S HOW I'D SAY IT BE
OPPORTUNITY CREDIT IT'S STATE
YOU KNOW- CENTER THAT'S HOW
EVERY YEAR. YOU FULFILL ALL OF
C. M. IF YOU ATTENDED IT IS
VERY WELL IT. AND MOST PEOPLE
TO ADVANTAGE OF THAT SO I DON'T
I THINK WE. OFTEN. ABOUT HERE
YOU KNOW IN THE ENTIRE UNITED
STATES IS EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
GOOD ACTORS CALIFORNIA HAS
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED. THIS FIFTY
NINE THOUSAND AND DIS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AT LEAST
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND PHARMACISTS
SO WHEN YOU START LOOKING AT
NUMBERS. YOU KNOW. OUR BOARD
OVERSEEING- A GROUP OF PEOPLE
IT'S MINUSCULE IT IS IN IN
REGARDS TO YOU YOU KNOW. OTHER
MEDICAL SPECIALTY THAT YOU
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT I'M
JUST ASKING TO THAT SINCE THE
BOARD ITSELF ACCORDING TO THE
REPORT ACTUALLY- PRUE C.
COURSES AND CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND WORKING WITH YOU
KNOW PERSONAL ASSOCIATIONS AND
SO FORTH THAT IS A WAY OF DOING
IT. IS THAT JUST WHAT WAS WHAT
DOES THE BOARD DO TO ASSURE
THAT THAT THE QUALITY THIS OF
THE CONTINUE EDUCATION RIGHT SO
FOR EXAMPLE DOES IT DOES IT
DOESN'T AVE TO. DOES THE US
THE CITY ANY SHARE WITH YOU THE
STANDARDS THAT THEY USED TO FOR
THEIR OWN COURSES YOU GO YUP I
LOOKED AT HIM TO LOOK GOOD YOU
KNOW GO FORTH AND THAT'S WHAT
WE APPROVED AND THAT'S FINE TOO
BUT I YEAH DAY. SO THERE IS A
MECHANISM THEY HAVE. TO TELL US
WHO THE SPEECHES ARE. HELLO YOU
KNOW THEY HAVE TO DISCLOSE IF
IS A SPONSOR SPONSOR IT LIKE
IT'S- TRY TO. SELL THE LATEST
ANKLE OR AYE AFTER THE VICE.
YOU KNOW GOING TO BE SOMEWHERE
WHO'S- YOU KNOW PANDERING. YOU
KNOW A BUSINESS SERVICES SO
YOU'RE TELLING IS THE BOARD
LOOKS AT THIS SO THAT'S OKAY SO
THAT THAT THAT DAY THAT THAT
THAT'S A GOOD ANSWER- AND I DO
THINK THAT- IT. WELL CERTAINLY
BELIEVE YOU REVIEW IT ON
INDIVIDUAL BASIS I DO ENCOURAGE
THE BOARD TO HAVE A MORE
FORMALIZED POLICY ON CONFLICTS
OF INTEREST RELATED TO SEE
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S JUST GOOD
AS A STANDARD I THINK YOU
PROBABLY. INHERENTLY DO THAT IN
YOUR VIEW THE COURSES BUT
THAT'S SOMETHING I BROUGHT UP
AND I BEGIN TO REALISE SKILLS
DIFFERENT- BUT IT'S IT IS ABOUT
IT IS A STATEMENT. ABOUT VALUES
AND- ALSO CONSUMER PROTECTION
THAT BECAUSE THAT IS A
REQUIREMENT FOR LICENSURE TO
HAVE C. E. SO YOU'D WANT TO BE
SURE THAT THE C. E. IS OF
APPROPRIATE STANDARDS OF LIKE
YOU ARE REVIEWING THAT BECAUSE
YOU'RE REVIEWING THE SPEAKERS
AND SO FORTH SO THAT'S THAT'S
APPRECIATE THAT. AND I JUST DO
ALSO ENCOURAGE BOARDS TO HAVE
IF THEY THEMSELVES ARE
ACTUALLY. APPROVING THE C. E.
EITHER THEY HAVE THEIR OWN
CONFLICT OF INTEREST STANDARDS
OR THAT THEY CAN DEFER TO A
PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATIONS AND
THAT THEY'VE REVIEWED IT AND
THEY FIND IT ACCEPTABLE JUST SO
THAT WE ENSURE THAT THE C. E.
IS ALSO. YOU KNOW NOT OVERLY-
DO YOU KNOW INFLUENCE LET'S
CONFIRM THE COMMERCIAL
INFLUENCE THAT IT'S ACTUALLY C.
E. AND NOT A MARKETING PLACE-
IT SOUNDS LIKE THAT'S KIND OF
INHERENT WHAT YOU'RE DOING BUT
WOULD JUST SAY THE ENTER YOU TO
CONSIDER. A CONFLICT AND POLICY
FOR YOUR C. APPROVED. THANK
THAT'S GREAT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND-
WILL BRING THAT UP TO THE BOARD
MEETING THE BOARD. DECEMBER
ELEVENTH ON MAKE SURE H. AND
ADDS THAT. WORK ON. PROTECTS
THANK YOU FOR THAT. THAT EIGHTY
YEAR UNTIL. YOUR FEEDBACK THIS.
OKAY WHAT THE YOU AND I FOR
DEBT FREE. TO WORK BOARD IS. TO
THE TO SEE AND- SENDS DONE. AND
FIND AND THEN I GUESS THE OTHER
QUESTION CAN THIS IS A QUESTION
OF HOW TO CREATE. BOARD BUT
PRIOR ON AT THE- THE IN. OF THE-
AND IN THE- FEES FROM THE- DOJ
AND- I RECOGNIZE THAT THAT'S
NOT AND FOR THE TIGHTLY UNDER
CONTROL- CHECKED. PREY WASN'T-
BUT- TO WHAT DEGREE HE- WERE.
YOUR IS YOUR BOARD BEING GIVEN
ANY JUSTIFICATION OR
EXPLANATION AS TO THEIR C.
INCREASE AND- ANY FEEDBACK YOU
WANNA GIVE US IS THE
LEGISLATURE IS WE'VE ACTUALLY
PASSED THE BUDGET. SO THAT'S
OUR RESPONSIBILITY. IN TERMS OF
THE IMPACT IT'S HAVING. ON BOTH
YOUR BOARDING YOUR LICENSEES.
RIGHT SO DON'T KNOW THE- THREE-
PANEL. TO YOU- THE IN THE
OFFICE- IT WAS KIND OF BY.
STRONACH US BREAKS AT THE 30%
IN THE SPRING AND SMALL BORE-
WHAT WE DO SEE RIGHT NOW YOU
KNOW REPORT CASES ON THERE WAS
A CAR WHERE. DID YOU SEE AN
BEST FOR SHORT. HERE UNDER THE
WORKS AND. DO SEEM TO BE
GETTING ALSO GOING TO INCREASE
THEIR IN IN FORCE INVESTING. IN
SEOUL WATER WAS K. THAT WON'T
BE EATING INVESTED THIS IS A
GUY STAFF UP ALONG WE SEE THE
IS CLOSE ARE COAL SENT OUT TO
THE AGE USED WHY. SIX THE
WARNING IT WOULD BE A GRADUAL-
LOOKING FOR SOME CASES BUT ALL
THE SUDDEN WE INVESTIGATORS
WERE ALL STEPPED UP ON THIS
RECURRING CASES WE'RE GOING TO
BE EACH OFFICE. YEAH THAT. OR
ARE PRETTY HARD ON WE DID GET A
FIFTEEN. THANK ALL OF YOU
WORKING ON HE. THREE THREE
THREE ZERO. THAT WAS ANOTHER
THAT HAVE IN PAPER. TO BE SURE
TO SUNSET BUT I THINK WE HAVE A
WE CAN A DIFFERENT PATHWAY ON.
THAT BILL RIGHT NOW WE'RE THE
MIDDLE IMPLEMENTING. REACH THAT
SHE SHOW. WITH AND- FOR YEARS A
SO 12-1 FUND CONDITION RESEARCH.
OKAY THANKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR PAN AND WE THE BOY
WORK ON THE CONSOLE POLICY
THAT'S THE YOU HAVE RAISED
MAKES GOOD SENSE TO ME. EITHER-
QUESTION ARE COMMON HERE IN THE
FOR MEMBERS LOOK ON OUR FOR
LINES SEE IF THERE ARE. CALLER
WHO HAVE HANDS UP I DON'T SEE
ANY. SO AN OPEN. BUT WE DO HAVE
A- HANDS UP. PARDON ME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON. FOR MISSING
YOUR YOUR HAND BUT I SEE IT NOW
AND WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- SENATOR
GLAZERS SHARES WELL AND ALSO
TRUE LOW. FOR THIS A VERY
pFROM B. AND B. C. THANK YOU FOR
THAT DR PAN- JUST TO KIND OF.
GO JUST A LITTLE BIT FURTHER
FROM YOUR LAST QUESTION ABOUT
FINANCE AND FUNDING I THINK ONE
OF THE MOST PRESSING THINGS
THAT WE ARE- FACING EVEN THOUGH
IT MAY NOT BE A LARGE AMOUNTS-
BECAUSE OF. YOUR SMALL AND IN
ONE SENSE BUT VERY VERY
THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
PROJECTING- SOME LOS. I KNOW
THE CHIU- OUT- WITH- ER I AM
MRG. TO DO SO STUDIES ON
INCREASE FOR. TO BE A TO MEET
THE NEEDS BUT TO BE ANYTHING TO
IT. THE DECREASE IN REVENUE IN
OTHER WORDS IT'S ALMOST LIKE
IT'S BEEN A FREEFALL FROM THE
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN SCHOOL YEAR TO
A PROJECTED TWENTY TWENTY ONE-
RIGHT HERE SO. IS THERE
ANYTHING- IN PARTICULAR THAT IS
GIVING US INDICATORS ARE
REASONS WHY THERE ARE- THERE
ARE- DECREASES IN REVENUE. YES
SO BASICALLY- HERE'S HERE'S A
LITTLE HISTORICAL BACKGROUND
JUST BEFORE I GOT HERE- THE
LAST FEEDING CREASE- FOR A PVC
WATER IN TWO THOUSAND FOR THE
LICENCES BY ANNUAL WAS NINE
HUNDRED DOLLARS AS I TOOK OVER
THE POSITION I STARTED SEEING
WORKS FINE CONDITION BEING
COMPLETED ON. THERE'S A WHOLE
LOT OF FACTORS RIGHT NIECES ONE
UP STAFF SERVICES PAY.
EVERYTHING WENT OUT SO SINCE
TWO THOUSAND FOUR THERE WAS NO-
SPEICHER DEVOTIONAL FOR YOU
KNOW ADDITIONAL FEE INCREASES
JUST MAINTAINING THE COST OF
RUNNING THE OFFICE RUNNING THE.
BUSINESS ALONG SO WE COULD
EIGHT I ASKED THE LEGISLATURE
ON. FOR TRIPLE D. INCREASE TO
DOLLARS FOR MAKES. ELEVEN
HUNDRED DOLLAR FOR EACH YEARS.
SO BASICALLY EACH DOCTOR PAID-
HUNDRED DOLLARS ON BECAUSE IT'S
A BUYING MEANS. AND THEN. ONCE
DID OUR STUDYING MISTER WE-
THAT OWN IT WAS THOSE. AT. THE
YEAR CAME CREE- THE CALL. WITH
NIECES ACTUALLY ARABS
EVERYTHING IT WOULD JUST WASN'T
ENOUGH BECAUSE WE DID CHANGE TO
IT TO IT NOW THROUGH A B. THREE
THREE ZERO WELL IN THE END FEE
HER BODY FEE START EIGHT SO IT
JUST MAKES FROM WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE FEES. IT YOU LOOK AT THE
TRENDS BACK INTO THOUSAND FOUR
IN TILL NOW THEY'RE JUST
THEY'RE WATSON ANY. PLAN PUT IN
PLACETO KIND OF NEED THOSE
NEEDS AS AS TIME WHEN ONE. IN
WE ALSO CONTRA COSTA ON ALL OF
OUR MEETINGS NOW WHAT CASTLES
CITY US SOME. OUT OF AN HIT WE
ALREADY HAD A HELLO YOU.
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE TO CHEER
YOU NEED OTHER REPORT CLICK
HERE- WE ARE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
OFFICE EFFICIENCY PLEASE YOUR
CHECKING OR PROBLEMS REMOTELY.
IN AROUND- SO YEAH BILLS. I
DIDN'T PREDICT OF THE NINETEEN
BUT WE WERE SET UP AND WE
DIDN'T HAVE TO LOCAL LAW.
MAKING ANY OTHER EXPENSES.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I THINK
I WOULD AGREE WITH STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS- ESPECIALLY ON
ISSUE NUMBER ONE AND THAT WOULD
BE- THAT- YOU ALL SHOULD BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE A- BREAKDOWN OF
SERVICES RECEIVED FROM DCA
ESPECIALLY WITH THE INCREASES
THAT ARE COMING YOUR WAY- JUST
TO SEE WHAT KIND OF AN IMPACT-
THERE ARE- PROGRAMMING. ABOUT
EFFICIENCIES SO. NUMBER ONE
WHERE. RIGHT AND WE DO HAVE A
SHARED SERVICES AGREEMENT WITH
NBC- THEY DO ARMED FORCES
INTAKE IN SOME BETTER IT STUFF
FOR US AND THAT USUALLY IS A
LITTLE MORE INVOLVED- FORTY ONE
HUNDRED OR FOUR FORTY ONE
THOUSAND. GLOBAL SHARED
SERVICES. IT I WOULD HIRE A PER
STEVE AT HOME IT WOULD BE FAR
MORE- EXTENSIVE. TOOK TO HIRE A
POSITION ON BECAUSE NO ONE TO
PAY THEM. NOT BEEN IN ALL THAT
AND PRO AROUND. EIGHTY EIGHT
THOUSAND. SO THE SURE SERVICES
AND IS A CAR SAVINGS TO US ON.
YEAH OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU AS MEMBER GRAYSON
ONE A IN ANY OTHER CALLING HAS
ANY QUESTIONS SO INDICATE NOT
WE'RE GONNA GO TO OF THOSE WHO
ARE HERE IN THE CAPITAL OR ON
THE PHONE LINES FOR TESTIMONY I
DON'T SEE ANY HANDSUP CHECKING
WITH TECHNICAL STAFF TO MAKE
SURE I'M NOT MISSING A MEMBER-
GOOD. SO WE'RE GOING TO GET NOW
GO TO THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
WRITTEN BY THOSE HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS TO COME FORWARD IF
THEY HAVE TESTIMONY. I DO NOT
SEE ANYONE WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE- DO NOT SEE
ANYONE THERE SO WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO THE PHONE LINES-
MODERATOR WOULD YOU ASK IF
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC TESTIMONY. ON
AGENDA ITEM NUMBER TO THE
PODIUM TRICK MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA SO INDICATE. THANK
YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME YOU
MAY PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN THAT'S
ONE ZERO. WE DO HAVE ONE LINE
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. TRAFFIC
PLEASE INVITE THEM TO CUT TO
PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU LINE SEVENTEEN ONE SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS FOR
INSTANCE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AFTER CONNECTICUT
LOCATION LIKE TO SPREAD
DISSOCIATION SUPPORT OF THE
PMDC IN APPRECIATION THE
EFFORTS TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
OUR LIFE THE- THEY ALSO LIKE TO
SUPPORT SPECIFICALLY PROPOSED
POLICY CHANGE THAT APPLY THE
SAME PROFESSIONALS CULTURE
CANADA CURRENTLY BY THE INDIAN
INDIO STOP SUPPLY TO DOCTORS OF
PODIATRIC MEDICINE. GIVEN THE
VASCULARITY FROM THE PRAXIS THE
PHILLIES WHERE THE TREE FROM
SURGERY AND PATIENTS THEY SERVE
IT JUST MAKES SENSE THEY ALSO
SHARE THE SAME DISCLOSURE
STANDARDS AFTER. AND DO CALL
THAT THOSE DISCLOSURES BOGUS
OFFENSES INVOLVING SAFETY CDMA
WELCOMES FURTHER DISCUSSION
OTHER PRACTICE MATTERS WERE
ALSO MAY BE APPROPRIATE TO
DISCREPANCIES BETWEEN THE YOU.
IN INDECENT. USING A PROGRAM
ACCESS THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR
TALKING. THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
BHATTARAI OR ANYONE ELSE IN KEY
TO PROVIDE TESTING ON THE AND
TWO. NO LINES AND IT BECAUSE-
ALL RIGHT WE'LL JUST MAKE IT
ALL FIVE LAST CALL FOR ANYONE
WHO WANTS TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY ON THE REVIEW OF THE
PUTTING OUT YOUR MEDICAL BOARD
PLEASE. SO INDICATE TO THE
OPERATOR SO WE CAN HEAR YOUR
TESTIMONY LAST LAST CALL THERE.
IF THERE IS ANYONE THAT ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO GIVE THEIR
TESTIMONY PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR NO LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
MODERATOR FOR YOUR GOOD WORK
AND- WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CLOSE THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
PORTION OF OUR HEARING NOW WE
WANT TO THANK A DOCTOR NANCY
AND MR NAZARIAN FOR. YOUR
STEWARDSHIP AND LEADERSHIP OF
THE BOARD- WE APPRECIATE THE
INPUT AND TESTIMONY THAT YOU
PROVIDED WE LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR- FURTHER CONSIDERATIONS OF
THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED BY MEMBERS- HERE TODAY
AS WELL AS IN THE STAFF REPORT.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU IN THE COMING WEEKS
TO- REVIEW AND- PUT FORWARD. I
HAD A- ACCENTUATION. OF YOUR
BOARDS THANK YOU BOTH VERY
MUCH. AND WITH THAT WE ARE
GOING TO CLOSE AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER TWO AND MOVED TO AGENDA
ITEM NUMBER THREE- THAT IS THE
REVIEW OF THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES. LIKE TO
INVITE THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
BOARD CRISTINA WONG AND THE
ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE OFFICER
STEVE SO- GRIN TO A TO JOIN US
HERE- IN OUR HEARING. OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
THOSE TWO INDIVIDUALS AND WE
WOULD INVITE YOU TO PROVIDE. AN
OPENING STATEMENT. GOOD MORNING
SENATOR GLASSER AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND CRISTINA LONG VICE CHAIR
FOR THE BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES AND A LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER. WITH ME
TODAY IS THE BOARD'S ASSISTANT
EXECUTIVE OFFICER STEVE
SODERBERGH BUT IN LEGISLATIVE
LEGISLATION MANAGER ROSE
ENHANCE AND ENFORCEMENT.
MANAGER MILO MCMANUS. WE WANT
TO THANK COMMITTEES FOR THEIR
WORK AND ASSISTANCE DURING THE
SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY TO
SHARE WITH YOU THE ORDER OF THE
BOARD SINCE OUR LAST SUNSET TO
REVIEW. THE MORE REGULATE.
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONS
LICENSE MANAGE LICENSED
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST.
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKERS. LICENSED PROFESSIONAL
CLINICAL COUNSELORS AND
LICENSED EDUCATIONAL
PSYCHOLOGISTS. PROTECTING
CONSUMERS RESPONDING TO
EMERGING TRENDS IN MENTAL
HEALTH PRACTICE AND THE NEEDS
OF THE PROFESSIONS WE REGULATE
GUIDANCE US AS WE SEEK A
LEGISLATIVE AND REGULATORY
CHANGES TO REVISE OUR EXISTING
LAW AND REGULATIONS. I AM
PLEASED TO HIGHLIGHT A FEW
EXAMPLES OF OUR WORK WHICH
INCLUDES THE FOLLOWING. THE
FIRST ONE IS EXAMINATION
RESTRUCTURE. EFFECTIVE JANUARY
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE BOARD
REVISED THE SEQUENCE OF THE
LICENSURE EXAMINATION PROGRESS.
THE NEW EXAMINATION'S SEQUENCE
NOW REQUIRES ALL ASSOCIATES TO
TAKE THE CALIFORNIA LAW AND
ETHICS EXAMINATION WITHIN THEIR
FIRST YEAR OF REGISTRATION.
PREVIOUSLY ALL EXAMINATION
CANDIDATES WERE REQUIRED TO
TAKE THE LICENSURE EXAMS AFTER
COMPLETION OF THEY WERE
SUPERVISED WORK EXPERIENCE
HOURS. THE NEW SEQUENCE
DEMONSTRATES TO THE PUBLIC
THAT'S AN ASSOCIATE WHO PASSED
THE CALIFORNIA LAW AND ETHICS
EXAMINATION IS KNOWLEDGEABLE OF
THE LAWFUL AND ETHICAL
PRACTICES THAT GOVERN THEIR
PROFESSION. THE CLINICAL EXAM
IS THEN ADMINISTERED. TO THE
COMPLETION OF SUPERVISED
EXPERIENCE HOURS ASSESSING
CANDIDATES CLINICAL KNOWLEDGE
AND COMPETENCY. ADDITIONALLY
THE EXAMINATION RESTRUCTURE
PROVIDES THE BOARD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO USE TO NATIONAL
CLINICAL EXAMINATIONS LICENSURE
IN CALIFORNIA. NATIONAL
CLINICAL MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELING EXAMINATION- IT'S
FOR THE LICENSED PROFESSIONAL
CLINICAL COUNSELORS AND OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL REPORTS
NATIONAL CLINICAL EXAMINATION
IS FOR THE LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKERS. THE USE OF THE
NATIONAL EXAMINATION IN
CALIFORNIA PROVIDES A
STREAMLINED PATHWAY TO
LICENSURE IN OTHER STATEFOR
CALIFORNIA LICENSEES. THE
SECOND EXAMPLE IS THE
SUPERVISOR SUPERVISION WORK
EXPERIENCE AND SUPERVISOR
REQUIREMENTS. THE BOARD
SUCCESSFULLY SOUGHT TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS TO
OBTAIN SUPERVISED WORK
EXPERIENCE BY ELIMINATING THE
VARIOUS CATEGORIES OR BUCKETS
TO COMPLETE SO QUALIFIED FOR
LICENSURE. CANDIDATES NOW HAVE
ONLY TWO CATEGORIES CLINICAL
SERVICES AND NON CLINICAL
SERVICES TO COMPLETE THE BOARD
ALSO STRENGTHENED THE
QUALIFICATIONS TO BECOME A
SUPERVISOR AND BERMAN DEFINES
IT RESPONSIBILITIES OF A
SUPERVISOR TO IMPROVE. THE
QUALITY OF SUPERVISION. THE
NEXT EXAM IS ANGUISH AS A
SECOND LANGUAGE RECOGNIZING THE
DIVERSITY IN CALIFORNIA THE BOY
WAS SUCCESSFUL IN THIS PROPOSAL
TO ALLOW EXAMINATION CANDIDATES
FOR WHOM ENGLISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE ADDITIONAL TIME TO
TAKE A LICENSURE EXAMINATIONS.
THE REGULATIONS BECAME
EFFECTIVE ON OCTOBER FIRST.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. THE LAST BUT
NOT LEAST IS THE LICENSE
PORTABILITY. ON SEPTEMBER
TWENTY SEVENTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN GOVERNOR NEWSOM SIGNS
THAT THE BOARD'S LICENSE
PORTABILITY BILL WHICH IS THE
SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY NINE
NINE EIGHT. THIS BILL REMOVES
BARRIERS TO LICENSURE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR OUT OF STATE
LICENSED APPLICANTS. EFFECTIVE
JANUARY FIRST WITH TWENTY
TWENTY LICENSED MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPIST LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS AND
LICENSED PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELORS WHO ARE LICENSED IN
ANOTHER STATE OR AT LEAST TWO
YEARS MAY APPLY FOR LICENSURE
IN CALIFORNIA UNDER THE NEW
STREAMLINED PROCESS. THIS WILL
HELP INCREASE ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT OF ALL
CALIFORNIA'S A SENSE TO IMPROVE
LICENSE PORTABILITY IS SERVING
AS A MODEL FOR CHANGE
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY. THE
NEXT ONE IS THE CULPRIT
NINETEEN RESPONSE WILL CALL THE
NINETEEN WAS NOT ADDRESSED THE
BOARD TO ORIGINAL SUNSET TO
RECORDING TWENTY NINETEEN. THE
THE SPEND DOWN MAKE SHOULD BE
NOTED. WITH A MINIMAL IMPACTS
THE SERVICES THE BOY WAS ABLE
TO TRANSITION MOST OF THE STAFF
TO REMOTE WORK SETTING. THIS
REQUIRED NOT ONLY EQUIPPING
STAFF WITH THE NECESSARY
HARDWARE BUT ALSO TRAINING
STAFF ON NEW PROCEDURES FOR
SCANNING AND RETRIEVING
APPLICATION DOCUMENTS
ELECTRONICALLY. THE WATER WAS
ALSO ABLE WITH THE ASSISTANCE
OF THE DEPARTMENT TO RESPOND TO
ISSUES AFFECTING CURRENT
LICENSEES THROUGH THE WAIVER
PROCESS. ADDITIONALLY THE BOARD
HAS UTILIZED ITS WEBSITE AND
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS IN ORDER
TO ENSURE APPLICANTS AND
LICENSEES ARE KEPT UP TO DATE
OF EMERGING ISSUES. MORE
EXAMPLES OF THE BOARD SUCCESSES
ARE DETAILED IN THE SUNSET
REVIEW REPORTS THE BOARD
CONTINUOUSLY WORKS TO ENSURE
EFFICIENCY AND ADVOCACY
OPERATIONS TO PROVIDE THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF SERVICE TO ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY AND SURE
CALIFORNIANS ARE PROTECTED AND
HAVE ACCESS TO QUALITY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING OUR WORK. AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY AND
WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE REGARDING THE PORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS LONG FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- I
WANT TO INVITE ANY OF MEMBERS
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS ARE ON THE
PHONES TO- ASK QUESTIONS AND I
SEE SENATOR PAN'S HAND IS UP
AND WE WELCOME. GOOD SENATOR
FROM SACRAMENTO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- CALCULATOR AND- AGAIN MY
THANKS THE OF FORT FIRST-
PRESENTATION I DID HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS BASED ON THE REPORT
THAT WE RECEIVED- FIRST OF ALL.
IN RELATION TO ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR WHICH IS SUPERVISION- HE
PERHAPS ELABORATE A BIT ON HOW
THE BOARD INSURERS- THAT
SUPERVISORS ARE. NOT
SUPERVISING MORE REGISTRANTS
ARE TRAINEES AND AUTHORIZED
EIGHT BECAUSE BASICALLY ONE BE
SURE THAT. THE SUPERVISORS ARE
ABLE TO SUPERVISE APPROPRIATELY
AND THE TRAINEES ARE GETTING
THE EDUCATION THEY NEED SOMEONE
WHO USED TO BE A RESIDENCY
TRAINING DIRECTOR I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO BE SURE THAT
ARE. THE FACT THAT FACULTY ARE
SPENDING ENOUGH TIME TO THE
BILL EDUCATE TRAINEES OF THE
TRAINEES ARE JUST SIMPLY LEFT
OUT TO DO CLINICAL WORK WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT SUPERVISION AND
GUIDANCE- AS TO DATE BOTH WITH
THEIR OWN EDUCATION ALSO FOR
THE QUALITY CARE THAT THE-
THAT- OF PATIENTS ARE RECEIVING
SO CAN YOU PERHAPS ELABORATED
MORE ON- THE ANSWER TO THAT.
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR. YES I CAN I
ANSWER THAT- MANY OF OUR ISSUES
THAT WE BROUGHT UP I WAS GONNA
MENTION THIS BEFORE- WE ARE WE
DO HAVE TO COMMITTEES COMING UP
ON THIS ONE WOULD BE DEFINITELY
ADDRESSED IN OUR LICENSING
COMMITTEE. AND THEN WE ALSO
HAVE A TELEHEALTH COMMITTEE
WHICH WE'RE GONNA BE ANSWERING
ARE WORKING ON A LOT OF THESE
ISSUES BUT IN REGARDS TO THE
TRAINING AND SUPERVISION- WE DO
RECOGNIZE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THAT THE REGISTRANTS AND
TRAINEES ARE GETTING YOU KNOW
THAT. REALLY. SOUND- SOUNDS. SO
HAVE. IN THE LAST YEAR IN THE
YEARS BEFORE WE HAD A
SUPERVISION COMMITTEE. THE
SETTLERS AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE
LEGISLATION GOING THROUGHAND-
SOME OF THAT WILL BE IN PLACE
NEXT YEAR IS TO REALLY
STRENGTHEN UP- REALLY TO
STRENGTHEN UP THE ROLE OF A
SUPERVISOR TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY KNOW WHAT THEIR ROLE IS.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
SUPERVISOR HE KNOWS WHAT THEIR
SUPERVISOR'S ROLE IS- PART OF
THE CHANGES THAT WE HAVE MADE-
THERE'S GOING TO BE NOW A
SUPERVISOR RESPONSIBILITY
STATEMENT WHERE BASIC YES
SUPERVISORY AGREEMENT- THAT
MICHELIN THE SUPERVISOR STARTS
THE SUPERVISION. THEY WILL HAVE
TO HAVE A DISCUSSION WITH THE
SUPERVISED THE ABOUT. WHAT EACH
AND EVERYONE WILL- IN TWENTY
TWO. TWO WE ARE GOING TO
ACTUALLY BEGIN. HAVING THE
SUPERVISORS REGISTER WITH THE
BOARD I'M DOING A- A SELF
EVALUATION CERTIFICATION TO
SHOW THAT THEY HAVE ALL THE
NECESSARY. ALL THE NECESSARY
QUALIFICATIONS TO SUPERVISE AND
ADDITIONALLY THERE IS A
COMPONENT THAT WE'RE PUTTING IN
PLACE FOR THE SUPERVISOR WILL
ACTUALLY HAVE A- WELL ACTUALLY
HAVE A CHANCE TO DO A REVIEW A
YEARLY REVIEW I'LL READ THIS-
SO. THAT'S KIND OF HOPING STRAY
UP STREET REQUIRE- WE CONTINUE
TO DO AS WE CONTINUE TO WORK IN
OUR LICENSING COMMITTEES NEXT
YEAR. SO A LOT OF THIS IS. SO
THAT ANSWERS- SORT OF THE CALL
AS PRESHEAF THAT AT ONE OF THEY.
THE YOUNG LADY IS KERN PRACTICE
I JUST WANTED. IS SO WE HAVE
USED THAT'S WILL BE SIGNED AN
AGREEMENT AND WILL BE EDUCATING
THEM OR BE SURE THAT THEY HAVE
THE RESPONSIBILITIES BUT FOR
EXAMPLE. IF THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
RISING TRAINEES AND DETAINEES
ARE SEEN PATIENTS. DO YOU HAVE
A WAY OF BEING ABLE TO ONE LINK
BACK- SAY TRAINEES ALL THE
PATIENT THAT THE SUPERVISOR
DOES NEED TO SIGN OFF THAT THEY
WERE INVOLVED IN THE CARE OF
THE PATIENT IS A SUPERVISOR SO
THAT IF THERE IS A- EVENT THAT
HAPPENED OR- THE QUALITY WASN'T
THERE. ON THE TRAIN HE AND TO
THE TRAINEE ISN'T THE ONLY ONE
THAT'S TIED TO THAT. AND THEN
IN ADDITION TO THAT- SO I GUESS
THAT FIGURED OUT LEVEL KIND OF
DOING THE OTHER THING TO KEEP
IN MIND IS THAT. THERE COULD BE
AGREEMENTS THAT CHENEY IS NOT
IN A POSITION TO CRITIQUE A
SUPERVISOR RIGHT. SO AND TO
EXPECT THE TRAINEE TO BRING UP
THAT THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH THE
SUPERVISION I THINK IS-
PROBABLY NOT A VERY GOOD WAY OF
DOING THINGS IT'S- SO. THAT IS
GONNA BE IN THE INCUMBENT ON
THE BOARD OR THE BOARD THROUGH
SOME OTHER TYPES OF YOU KNOW-
ORGANIZATION OR AGENCY THAT HAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE SUPERVISORS
SURE THAT THE SUPERVISOR IS
DOING THEIR JOB. SO IT'S GREAT
FOR THE SUPERVISOR SELF
CERTIFIED BUT JUST WHAT THE
FEEDBACK LOOPS TO IDENTIFY IF
THERE IS A PROBLEM. NO ANSWER-
AND I MEAN I CAN'T SPEAK FOR
THE WORK BUT I KNOW THAT IT IS
NOT A FOCUS OF US AND THAT'S
WHAT. I MEAN THE SUPERVISION.
REQUIREMENTS WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON AND SO WELL
DEFINITELY THINK. OKAY OKAY.
ANYTHING WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT PASS A RESPONSIBILITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY- THAT EVENTUALLY
LED TO THE BOARD. BUT YOU KNOW
THERE MAY BE OTHER INTERNAL.
PROCESSES AS WELL OKAY- THE
OTHER QUESTION I HAD CENTER
PANICKING HOLDERS ONLY TO
FOLLOW UP ON THAT AND WE CAN SO
YOUR NEXT QUESTION BECAUSE I. I
WAS ALSO LEFT US A LITTLE
CONFUSED ABOUT HOW SUPER VISIT
VISION HAPPENS. WITH- AND
TELEHEALTH. AND WHETHER THERE'S
A BORDERS STAB PROTOCOL IN THE
RIVER HE TO SPEAK THIS THE TELE.
PARTY THIS IN HOUSE. ACTUALLY
WORKS- WELLS I AM SUPER CAN
BEING WITH ALLOW SOME SUPER.
THROUGH HELLO. TELECONFERENCING
BUT IT HAS TO BE FACE TO FACE-
VIDEO- SO I'M NOT SURE. THEY
STILL HAVE TO READ THEY ARE
STILL THEM THE STAFF THERE ARE
REQUIRED FOR THE IN THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR SUPERVISION
THE AMOUNT OF HOURS FOR-
SUPERVISE HOURS FOR ACTUALLY
CLINICAL HOURS IT HASN'T
CHANGED THAT WE ARE FOR NEED TO
ASK FOR THE CODE NINETEEN
RESPONSE WE ARE ALLOWING SOME
OF THOSE USED TO BE THEY HAD TO
HAVE IN PERSON- FOR SOME OF OUR
GROUPS IT HAD TO BE ALL IN
PERSON BUT WE ARE ALLOWING SOME
VIDEO CONFERENCING. RIGHT SIR
HOW ARE YOU HANDLING
SUPERVISION- IN THAT TELEHEALTH
SPACE- WHAT WE RELY ON- IS
BASICALLY THE SUPERVISOR TO.
DOCUMENT I MEAN THE SUPERVISOR
IN THE SUPERVISOR HAVE TO
DOCUMENT THAT THEY ACTION
ACTUALLY HAS BE SUPERVISION
THROUGH- THROUGH A SUPERVISOR
AGREEMENTS AND WEEKLY WEEKLY
OUR LAWNS- BUT TO ACTUALLY. WE
CAMERA AND THERE'S REALLY
NOTHING THAT AT THIS POINT THAT
WE CAN REALLY I GUESS WE DON'T
REALLY HAVE ANY AUDIT HUESO
AUDIT THAT. I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT MAKES SENSE WHAT DO YOU
HAVE ANY PROTOCOLS AND HOW IT'S
TO BE DONE. PROPERLY. WE HAVE
NOTHING IN OUR IN OUR
LEGISLATIONS REGULATIONS OUT
SOME PROPERLY- I THINK THERE'S
BEST PRACTICES THAT WE HAVE. I
DON'T- WHERE IT SAYS FOR THE
WESTERN PROVIDER SHOULD BE
DOING THAT'S IN THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY STATEMENT- BUT
WE COULD DEFINITELY CLARIFY YOU
KNOW WITH THE TELEHEALTH VIDEO
CONFERENCING STUFF DEFINITELY
KNOW SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
GREAT TO HAVE I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THAT SENATOR
PAN RIGHT TO THE INTERRUPTED
LIKE TO GO BACK TO YOU FOR
FURTHER QUESTIONS THANK YOU AND
I APPRECIATE THE FOLLOW UP AND
I GUESS JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON
WHAT YOU JUST ASKED ABOUT I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO HAVE
PROTOCOLS- THAT- OF. AND
INTERNET ACCOUNTABILITY AND
AGAIN IT MAY NOT BE NECESSARY
THE BOARD LEVEL BUT FOR EXAMPLE
YOU KNOW TOOK THE TIME TO
SPENDING WHETHER YOUNG TWENTY
FACE TO FACE AND ARE QUOTE FACE
TO FACE AND A TELEHEALTH OR
AGAIN WITH THE PROPRIETOR C. IN
PLACE- YOU KNOW RECORDING OF
THE INTERACTION WITH REVIEW BY
THE SUPERVISOR AND SIGN UP
WHAT'S RIGHT TO DO THE TYPES OF
THINGS THAT. NEED TO BE
DETERMINED AND APPROPRIATE
STANDARDS BE ESTABLISHED- THE
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
APPROPRIATE SUPERVISION AND
QUALITY BECAUSE ULTIMATELY
TURNS PATIENT AT THE END TO
DESERVES TO GET THE HIGHEST
QUALITY NO MATTER WHO'S TAKING
CARE OF THEM AND THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY THE TRAINEE AS WELL
NEED TO BE TRAINED PROPERLY SO
THEY CAN DO INDEPENDENT
PRACTICE SO WE'LL LOOK FORWARD.
TO THE FOLLOW UP FROM THE BOARD
ON THAT. RIGHT OF DISMISSAL I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S PROBLEM
ABOUT SPEAK. SO ANY POTS. THE I-
CHINA. HELLO IF YOU WISH TO
TIENEN THIS RIGHT NOW PLEASED
RIGHT NOW OKAY THANK YOU SO
JUST A COUPLE ABOUT- THAT-
QUALITY AT THE OVER SUPPOSED
SO I AM SUPER. YOU KNOW I CAN
YOU'LL SEE BY. THAT SOME YOU
KNOW THE YOUNG SUPERVISION
TELECONFERENCING IT'S NO
DIFFERENT THAN INDIVIDUAL
ALTHOUGH WE ALL OF THIS- YOU
KNOW BEING TOGETHER SO- SO
QUALITY WISE I CAN GET NOW I
CAN BUY EXPIATION
EXPERIMENTALLY DOESN'T REALLY
GOING TO AFFECT MUCH AND THE
SECOND THING IS ABOUT THE
QUALITY OF THE SUPERVISION. AND
SO- GET UNDER A LAW- THE
SUPERVISORS ARE REQUIRED YOU
KNOW TO ONE TO TAKE- UNITS OF
FROM CONTINUING EDUCATION IN
REGARDING LINE ETHICS AND
SUPERVISED EXHIBITION IN ORDER
TO QUALIFY TO UNIFORM LOOKING A
SUPERVISOR. AND SO THAT IS
ACTUALLY REALLY IMPORTANT
MECHANISM TO ENSURE THAT YOU
KNOW THE SUPERVISORS THEMSELVES
HAPPY- THE KNOWLEDGE AND ALSO
TODAY SOME UNDERSTANDING ABOUT
THE MOST CURRENT PRACTICE AND
THE SECOND THING IS THAT YOU
KNOW FOR THE YOUNG OF THE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE QUALITY OF
THE- TRAINEES AND- THE
ASSOCIATES- OUR RUN IT ALSO
SETS IT WILL GET ON. TO HAVE
THREE THOUSAND A SUPERVISED
CLINICAL HOURS AND THEY HAVE TO
MEET WITH THEIR SUPERVISOR IN
AFRASIYAB COUPLE HOURS A WEEK
YOU KNOW TO TALK ABOUT CASES
AND GET ALL THE CHALLENGES SO I
DO BELIEVE THAT THIS MECHANISM
IS VERY VIGOROUS AND YOU KNOW
IN MY EXPERIENCE AND I DO IT'S
YOUR HOUSE- EXPERIENCE THAT TO
GET ONLINE. YEAH NATALIE
SUPERVISE SEES UNDER MY WING
THEY ARE DEFINITELY GONNA OF
QUALITY AND COMPETENCE YOU KNOW
TO SERVE OUR CUSTOMERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND IT JUST DIDN'T.
APPRECIATE AND MEDIA ASK YOU
QUESTIONS AND YOU ACTION OUR
SUPER- WHEN IT COMES TO- THE
SUPER THIS IS THIS. ALL SO OFF
ON THE CHART SO KNOW WHO'S
ULTIMATELY FOR THE CARE OF THAT
PAY IN ADDITION TO TRAINEE. SO
THE SUPER SUPERVISING IT IN
MEDICARE PATIENTS THE SU. IN
NAME IS ATTACK TO THAT. FOR
THAT THAT PATIENT CARE OF SO TO
THE SUPERVISOR ULTIMATE
RESPONSE FOR THE OF PATIENTS
RECEIVED IS THAT TRUE. WELL SO
THE TRAINEE IS DIFFERENT FOR
TRAINEES. IT'S I GUESS IT RUNS
AND ALL EXAM YOUR PROBABLY
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT CLEARE IT
ALSO THE TRAINEE TECHNICALLY IS
NOT BEING DONE AROUND THE UNDER
OUT YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
ASSOCIATED YES AND YET YOU KNOW
THERE ENOUGH THAT IS CONSIDERED
A PART OF THEIR PRACTICUM AND
YES YOU KNOW WHEN THEY- YOU
KNOW WHEN THERE'S SOME OF THAT
THE- THE TRAINEES YOU'RE A
PROVIDER SERVICE THEY HAVE TO
BE YOU'RE A SUPERVISED. BY THE
SUPERVISOR. SO I GUESS I THINK
IS A FREE STRAIGHT FOR QUESTION.
WHEN A SUPERVISOR. TRAINING
WRITING TO A PAY. THE SUPER.
ALSO SO OFF ON THE CHART AND
THERE FOR TAKES RISK. FOR THE
THAT EVEN THOUGH IS. THROUGH A
TRAINEE UNDER THEIR SUPERVISION
SO THERE IS LEGAL
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
SUPERVISOR FOR THE CARE THAT
WAS PROVIDED EVEN THOSE
PROVIDED THROUGH A TRAINEE THE
SUPERVISORS THAT TRUE. YES
OKAY. YEAH AND OUR TIME INTO I
THINK THIS. IS AN- THE TRAIN IS
ACTUALLY WORK UNDER THE- RIGHT
OKAY THAT. STILL IF THERE'S
PROBLEM THE SUPERVISORS
BASICALLY PUTTING YOUR LIFE ON
THE OKAY. THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
WANT TO KNOW AT THAT STOCKTON
AND THE DOW. IN THE CARE AND I
YEAH LET ME BE CLEAR FOR TH
RECORD YEAH THAT'S A ROSE THAT
HELPS THE LEAD TO MANAGER JUST
SO YOUR IDEAL OKAY I THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT. AT A POINT ABOUT THE
SUIT. AND FUTURE IF I MAY. YES
AHEAD OF. I ALSO LIKE TO SAY WE
REGARD TO SENATOR CANS QUESTION
ABOUT SUPERVISION TELE. MOVING
FOR- BUT CALL MAY NEED NOT HAVE
A TON OF THE FOR SUPERVISION BE
TO TELL. PRETTY COVERED IN
COVERT HAS REALLY HIGH SOME
AREAS OUR LAW NEEDS CLEAN AND
SHE- WITHIN FOR AND BOARD HAS
TO STOP ITSELF. CAN AND GOING
TO ITS FIRST IS GOING TO BE
JANUARY TWENTY IT'S TO BE ON
GOING INTO WE CAN COME WITH
THAT THE PROPOSAL ADDRESSED OF
THE PORTIONS OF THE LAW AND
REGULATIONS. THE CLERK SO WE
ARE AWARE OF THIS- AND WEDDINGS
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE HAVING.
DISCUSSION DRESS THEM. THANK
YOU THINK I'M MISSING. CENTER
PAN OKAY MOVES TO MY NEXT. OKAY
THAN ISSUE IS WHY I ACTUALLY UP
WITH ALMOST ALL HEALTH FOR
BOARDS- HAS TO DO IN COULD. AT.
ESTIMATE THAT- IN THE BACK TAPE
FIRST OF ALL- AM NOT SO WE JUST
REVIEW A THIRD REVIEW TODAY BY
YOU HAVEN'T FROM. ANY WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF THE LIGHTS. ARE
AT SELECT FOR AN- SO HE SAID
RAN NUMBER I DON'T KNOW WHAT
PERCENT IT IS. BUT MORE
DISTURBING. IS ALSO. THAT THE
AVERAGE PERCENTAGE OF LICENSEES
WHO FAILED THE BOARD SEE I DID-
FROM S. FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN HOURS 27%
WHICH IS A FAIRLY LARGE
PERCENTAGE AND IN FACT EVEN
MAKE NOTE THAT. IS THE MOST
FREQUENT. THE MOST FIVE IS
COMING VIOLATIONS FOR CITATION
ARE NUMBER OF. FAILURE TO
COMPLETE REQUIRED C. E. AND THE
MISREPRESENTATION OF THE C.
COMPLETED. SO THAT WOULD SAY TO
ME THAT THE CONTINUING
EDUCATION OVERSIGHT IS PERHAPS
A BIT PROFICIENT. AND- WE NEED
MORE DETAIL ON ON THAT AS WELL
SO CAN YOU SPEAK TO THE
PERCENTAGE OF LICENSEES THAT
ACTUALLY ARE BEING AUDITED
EACH. RENEWAL CYCLE FOR THEIR
CONTINUING EDUCATION. AND- A
THEN A WHAT L. IS IT. WHAT'S
BEING DONE WHEN THERE'S A- YOU
KNOW A VIOLATION RATE OF 27%
AND IT'S WE ARE MOST CUT WHEN
YOU'RE MOST COMMON CAUSES FOR
CITATION. SO CAN YOU SPEAK TO
WHAT THE BOARD IS DOING TO
ADDRESS THAT- DEFINITELY AND I
THINK I DON'T HAVE THE ACTUAL
PERCENTAGES BUT I THINK ONE. IN
THE PAST WE WERE DOING ABOUT
ONLY A ONE PERCENT- I'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT THE NUMBERS HERE FOR
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
WE GET FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY SIX.
THEY HAVE LIKE A ONE PERCENT- A
SAMPLE OR AUDIT- SO REALLY WITH
THE FAILURE RATE- WHAT WE'RE-
IT'S MOSTLY. LICENSEES NOT
UNDERSTANDING FULLY- WHAT ARE
THE REQUIRED- C. UNITS THAT
THEY HAVE TO GET THEY MAY KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE THIRTY SIX UNITS
THAT THEY HAVE TO GET BUT THEY
FORGET SOMETIMES THAT THERE'S A
SIX HOUR OF LAWN ETHICS THAT
THEY HAVE TO DO EVERY RENEWAL
CYCLE AND THERE'S OTHER
ADDITIONAL- YOU KNOW REQUIRED
COURSES FOR THAT FIRST YOU KNOW
IT SO THAT'S WERE SEEN I THINK.
MOST OF THE- IN THE FAILURE
RATES ARE IN THE HOUSE IT'S
NOT. COMPLETELY MISSING THIRTY
SIX HOURS THE OTHER THING THAT
WE'RE EXPERIENCING INSTANCE WE
DID GO TO. A WHILE BACK ABOUT
THREE YEARS AGO I THINK IT WAS
WE CHANGED OUR C. E. REQUIRE AS
C. E. APPROVAL AGENCIES- THIRTY
EIGHT SOME OF THE SCENES THAT
PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY GETTING DO
NOT QUALIFY. FOR OUR CURRENT
REQUIREMENTS SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE SEEING WHAT WE ARE DOING
NOW I THINK WHAT WE'VE TRIED TO
DO IS DEFINITELY MORE
EDUCATION. MORE NOTICES TO OUR
LICENSEES ABOUT WHAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE WITH SEEDS. AND WEBER
THESE ARE REQUIRED. AND THEN
FOR THE AUDIT PURPOSES WE'VE
ACTUALLY GONE AHEAD AND WE ARE.
THIS YEAR- WE HAVE A NEW
POSITION THAT IS BASICALLY
GOING TO BE. REALLY.
CONCENTRATING ON JUST THE- IN
THE- PROCESS WE WILL BE IN THE
YEAR. OUR AUDIENCE WILL ACT- BE
INCREASING ON THAT SO I'M
THINKING HOPEFULLY WITH.
FACTORY I MEANING. STAFF MEMBER
BEING ABLE TO YOU THAT AUDIT.
LAST- BUT IT'S MORE. TO WILL
SEEM. WHAT WE SEE YOU KNOW
PERCENT FAILURE RATE THE EX
OKAY SO I MEAN. IF YOU. ANY
ABERRATION THAT ANSWER THAT
YOU'RE INVESTING AND DOING THIS
IT'S ONLY- DOING 1% AND OF THAT
1% OF THE 27% FAILURE RATE. AND
AGAIN FOR THE REASONS USED TO
IT I MEAN THAT SOURCE THAT'S
REPRESENTS SAMPLE OF THE ENTIRE
SO- I THINK OF PERHAPS RATHER
BE EXAMINATION OF. WHETHER TO
SEE REQUIREMENTS PEOPLE ARE
UNDERSTANDING IT THIS LACK OF
CLARITY THERE TOO COMPLEX AND
MAYBE THEY'RE NOT BE SOME
SIMPLIFICATION ADULT LEARNING
IS PEOPLE USUALLY. IDENTIFYING
THEIR OWN DEFICIENCIES- SO I
DON'T KNOW HOW COMPLEX YOUR C.
REQUIREMENTS ARE BEYOND THE
NUMBER OF HOURS I THINK THERE'S
A BALANCE BETWEEN. HOW MANY
RESTRICTIONS YOU PUT ON IT LIKE
WHAT TYPES VERSES TOTAL NUMBER
OF HOURS AND 2 DEGREES THAT-
BUT- IS THAT I THINK THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO
BE FOLLOWED UP BECAUSE
OTHERWISE EFFECTIVELY WHATEVER
SEE POLICY YOU HAVE IS NOT.
BEING CARRIED OUT SO YOU MAKE A
GOOD TENSIONS REQUIRE PEOPLE TO
DO A CERTAIN TYPE OF C. BUT
SOUNDS LIKE THEY'RE NOT DOING
IT. AND SO THAT'S DID SOMEWHERE
WE GOTTA FIND IN A AND A
BALANCED THERE THE OTHER ISSUE
ALSO IS THAT AND I APPRECIATE
THAT THE BOARD- NO LONGER
ACTUALLY PROVES- SPECIFIC C. E.
BUT THEN- GOES THROUGH- THESE
VARIOUS. ORGANIZATIONS WHICH-
CERTAINLY SEEMS APPROPRIATE BUT
I DID- I DO NEED TO ASK IS. IS
THERE A BOARD POLICY- IN
REGARDS TO CONTENT BE SURE THAT
WHATEVER SEE PEOPLE TAKE- THAT
THERE'S A CONFLICT OF INTEREST
POLICY THAT- WELL I MEAN IS
THAT THERE'S NOT UNDUE
COMMERCIAL INFLUENCE ON THE
CONTENT OF THE CONTINUED
EDUCATION AND CERTAINLY THESE
ORGANIZATION MAY HAVE THEIR OWN
STANDARDS THAT ARE ACCEPTABLE
TO THE BOARD- TO ENSURE THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN FOR THAT
QUALIFIED SEE BUT I JUST WANNA
BE SURE THERE'S A MECHANISM IN
PLACE TO ENSURE THAT. THE C. E.
THAT PEOPLE ARE TAKING A IS NOT
UNDER UNDUE COMMERCIAL
INFLUENCE SO- CAN YOU SPEAK TO
THAT- YEAH ACTUALLY I WILL TO
GET BACK TO ON. BUT I KNOW
FIRST. WITH THE APPROVING
AGENCIES WE HAVE A OUR NEW
THERE FOR YOU NAY. OR AGENCY
SPACE- LICENSE LIES- SORRY AND
IN WHAT THE WORD IS LICENSE A
ASSOCIATE AND BASED EITHER ONE
THAT ACTUALLY IMPROVE YEAH
PROOFREADING EDUCATION
PROVIDERS THEY HAVE A MECHANISM
IN PLACE FOR UNION AND FOR- YOU
KNOW LOOKING AT THE QUALITY OF
SEEDS- WITHIN. WE DO HAVE A IN
A REGULATIONS WE DO HAVE IF A
NEW PROVIDER APPROVAL AGENCY
WANTS TO COME ON BOARD THEY
HAVE TO HAVE THAT CONFLICT OF
INTEREST. THEY MASS- SO THAT WE
KNOW THAT THAT IS IN PLACE I
HAVE TO CHECK AGAIN JUST TO
MAKE SURE ORIGINALLY WHEN WE
WERE LOOKING AT THESE
ASSOCIATIONS THE APPROVAL
AGENCIES- I AGREE THAT WE-
LOOKED AT THAT AND ADDRESS.
THAT BUT I WILL HAVE TO. A WHAT
VERSION OF THE DOES HAVE A PA.
IS YOU STAY AS THAT YOU'LL BE
LOOKING AT TO BE ENSURE THAT
THE AND THAT THE BODIES THAT
YOU HAVE ASSEMBLY DEFERRED TO
TWO. AFFORDABLE C. WHICH IS
FINE. ALSO HAVE A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST POLICY THAT IS.
ACCEPTABLE TO THE BOARD TO
ENSURE THAT- SEE THAT PEOPLE
ARE GETTING- MEETS THE
STANDARDS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD THANK YOU SENATOR PAT
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE QUESTIONS
HERE IN THE CHAMBER ON OUR
PHONE LINES AND ZOOM MANY
MEMBERS WITH. THEIR HANDS UP
PLEASE SO INDICATE. SEEN NINE I
HAD A COUPLE QUESTIONS THEN
WE'RE GONNA GO TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY- YOU'VE SPOKEN TO THE
ISSUE OF TELEHEALTH AND BECAUSE
OF IT. THE COVETED PANDEMIC IN.
HOW THAT HAS CHANGED OUR WORLD
IN SO MANY WAYS CAN YOU- SPEAK
A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THE BOARD HAS
EXPERIENCE IN REGULATING.
TELEHEALTH PROVIDERS.
TELEHEALTH PROVIDERS PER SE I
THINK WE CAN HAVE THIS- THAT
WAS THE FOCUS FOR
ADMINISTRATIVELY- LOOKING AT-
THE LICENSE IT'S REALLY IT'S
THAT'S RIGHT OR- IT'S HARD TO
REALLY. HE SAID THAT- AND
PERSONALLY I DON'T KNOW. WE-
BECAUSE UR TELEHEALTH
REGULATIONS ARE BASICALLY YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A LICENSE WITH IN
CALIFORNIA- YOU BASICALLY
PROVIDE TELEHEALTH- REGULATING
THAT IS A BIT TOUGH TO FIGURE
OUT IF PEOPLE ARE YOU KNOW IN
TWO WEEKS- NO PROVIDING
TELEHEALTH ARE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS THE LICENSEES ON THE
ONE ISSUE THAT WE HAVE- WE HAVE
HAD TO DEAL WITH OUR- LICENSE
THINGS FROM OTHER STATES- WITH
CLIENTS THAT TRANSFER BACK TO
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE FOR SOME
REASONS- JUST TRANSFERRING BACK
AND THEY WANTED THEY CONTINUE
READING CONTINUE READING OF
CARE- WORKING WITH THOSE-
LICENSEES UNFORTUNATELY AT THIS
POINT OTHER THAN A FINE FOR THE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICE ACT
FOR THIRTY DAY TEMPORARY- YOU
KNOW TEMPORARY LICENSES THAT
THEY CAN ACTUALLY TRANSFER YOU
KNOW THE CLIENT OVER TO
SERVICES WITHIN CALIFORNIA- AND
I HAVE TO TELL THEM THAT THEY
CAN'T. USE THAT- SO BEEN OF
TOUGH BUT THAT IS ONE OF THE
ISSUE THAT WE'RE BE LOOKING AT
WITH THEIR HELLO HOW- COMMITTEE
IS NOW PUTTING IN PLACE OF THE
I TEMPER WAIVER OR EMERGENCY
WAY FOR LICENSING. AT A WEEK
I'M- WELL I HAD THE BOARD'S IN
INCOME. ABOUT ON OR APP BAY
PROVIDERS IS THERE. FIVE SO.
HEY WE REALLY IT'S ONE OF THOSE
THINGS WHERE YOU'RE NOT AT THE-
IS NOT NICE. GONNA I DON'T
THINK THAT I'M I'D HAVE TO LOOK
TO SEE IF WE RISK ANY. I ALWAYS
LIKE TO SAY AND I WE I DO THINK
WE REINSTATE. MUCH AND PLANTS
ABOUT ALL RIGHT WELL IF YOU.
TAKE A AT THAT I. YOU DON'T
HAVE TO GO ON HE TAKE A LOOK AT
IT AND GIVE US YOUR FEEDBACK
THAT. RIGHT I'M SORRY. WELL
THEN THERE'S THE BROADER ISSUE
OF. DO YOU THINK THAT- THE
TELEHEALTH IS- YOU KNOW IT'S AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE DELIVERY
OF MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IS IT
A PART OF OUR WORLD AND IT'S
USEFUL AND HELPFUL AND- AS A
POSITIVE IDEA OF ANY BROADER
OBSERVATIONS ABOUT. TELEHEALTH
IN YOUR SPACE. I DON'T WANT TO
SPEAK FOR THE BOARD BUT I THINK
IT'S DEFINITELY I MEAN IT IS
NEEDED- ESPECIALLY FOR ACCESS
AND FOR ME AT THE ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IT
REALLY HELPS OUT SPECIALLY FOR
THOSE REMOTE AREAS- THE OTHER
THING THAT I LOOK AT- IS THAT
IT ACTUALLY WOULD INCREASE
POSSIBLY THAT ACCESS FOR- YOU
KNOW CULTURALLY COMPETENT IT
MAKES IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO
ACTUALLY ACCESS MANY- THERAPIST
MAYBE THAT IS MORE IN LINE WITH
THEIR- WITH THEIR JOURNEY IN
LIFE AND WHAT THEY ACTUALLY
HAVE TO DO SO I DEFINITELY- IT
IS DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT I.
PERSONALLY YOU KNOW I THINK IS
DEFINITELY NEEDED AND THE
EXPANSION OF THAT BUT YOU KNOW
REALLY LOOKING AT THE WITH OUR
MANDATE PUBLIC PROTECTION
DURING NEXT YEAR THE TELEHEALTH
REALLY GONNA LOOK AFFECTS YOU.
BECAUSE IT IS ONE OF THOSE.
IT'S REALLY WEIRD NEW WANTS TO
DEFINE. FIGURE OUT HOW TO
REALLY ENJOY. YOU KNOW THAT
PUBLIC PROTECTION IN THIS IN
THIS DIVERSE RIGHT. THAT'S
WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT. YES NEEDED
BUT WITH MORE. NOW WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO REALLY
REGULATE. ALL RIGHT WELL I
APPRECIATE YOUR OBSERVATION AND
OBVIOUSLY WE SHARE YOUR DESIRE
TO ENSURE THAT. THE DELIVERY OF
SERVICES IN ANY FORM IS TIME IT
PROPERLY- WITH THE- WHO ARE
PROPERLY TRAINED AND
SUPERVISED. I'LL GIVE YOU MY-
PERSONAL EDITORIAL. VIEW THAT.
IN THE MIDST OF THIS TERRIBLE
PANDEMIC WHERE EVERYTHING IS.
ONLY BAD THIS IS ONE PLACE- AND
WHICH- THEY PROVIDE A SMALL BIT
OF- HOPE FOR HOW WE CAN DO OUR
WORK BETTER IN THIS SPACE. THAT
TAP PROVIDING GREATER ACCESS AS
YOU INDICATED. I IN A WAY THAT
IS MOST RESPONSIVE TO THOSE WHO
NEED THAT HELP- NOT JUST WITH
AN EFFICIENCY BUT- CULTURAL
CONNECTION- IN OTHER IN OTHER
WAYS THAT I ONLY WENT IN THE
COURAGE YOU TO. CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT IT MORE DEEPLY AND
THOUGHTFULLY- AND PROVIDE US
WITH YOUR GUIDANCE AS TO HOW WE
MIGHT IF THERE ARE BARRIERS TO
THAT. THAT WORK- IN THE GOOD
THAT OUR MUTUAL GOALS OF HAVING
IT DONE PROPERLY THAT WE BREAK
DOWN THOSE BARRIERS BECAUSE WE
WANT PEOPLE TO GET THE HELP
THAT THEY NEED- WHICH IS SO
IMPORTANT- OKAY. WELL THAT THAT
CONCLUDES A MIKE MY QUESTIONS
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S OTHER ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED IN THE-
BACKGROUND PAPER WHICH WE LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR- RESPONSE TO
OUR ASK MEMBERS ONE LAST TIME
BEFORE WE GO TO THE PBLIC. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS HANDS UP. C.
NINE HERE IN THE CHAMBERS ARE
ON THE PHONE LINES ARE ON ZOOM.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE
PUBLIC. ASK ANYONE HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS OF THERE'S
TESTIMONY TO BE PROVIDED. C.
NINE OF ANY GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. C. NINE THERE WE'RE
GONNA GO TO OUR PHONE LINES TO
A MODERATOR IF YOU COULD ASK IF
THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY ON.
JAN ITEM NUMBER THREE THE
REVIEW WITH THE BOARD OF THE
HAVERHILL SCIENCES TO PLEASE SO
INDICATE TO YOU. THANK YOU. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT ON AGENDA ITEM NUMBER
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
YOU SHOULD HEAR A TONE
INDICATING THAT YOU COMPLEXITY
IN Q. AGAIN THAT COMMANDERS ONE
FOLLOWED BY. ZERO MISTER CHAIR
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE THREE
LINES IN Q. PLEASE INVITE THE
FIRST TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU ONE TWENTY TWO ZERO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND
AN ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTS
ONE OF THE LICENSEES AT THE
BOARD WE WORK CLOSE CLOSELY
WITH THE B. B. ASK. AND WE'VE
ALWAYS FOUND THEM TO BE VERY
RESPONSIVE TO OUR NEEDS AND
GOOD PARTNERS- ANY AT W. WHY
I'M ACTIVE IN GETTING AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY EIGHT PASS THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE ADDED B. B. S.
HAS- THAT WILL TAXIS AND WAYS
TO COMMUNICATE TO LICENSEES.
MAY HAVE HAD A HALF INTERACTION
WITH THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND THEY HAVE TAKEN OUR
SUGGESTIONS ON HOW TO MAKE IT
CLEAR FOR PEOPLE TO GO TO THE
LICENSURE PROCESS. SO WE HAVE
APPRECIATED. BURGER CHEF AND-
RECOMMEND THAT THIS CAN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY OF CONCERT-
OPERATOR CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY ONE
TO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS G. B. ERRORS
AND I REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELORS. EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
CAN ATTEND MORE INSTANCES
REGARDS AND YET PRODUCTS
NOTHING COULD NOT EIGHTEEN
TODAY'S HEARING. TOPIC
APPRECIATE OF THE BOWL- VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED BOARD IN SAN
YOU SUNSET. THE BOARD IS DOES
EXCITE JOB THE DAY WITH THE
PROFESSION. AND CHAIRS OUT AND
EVEN HAND. REGULATING ACTIVITY-
IN THE IN LICENSE WORLD- WE
APPRECIATE IT- ONE ALSO SEVERED
PORTION OF IT SB SIX SEVENTY
NINE SUPERBIKE SPELLING TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WHICH IS.
ESTABLISH THE NATION'S LEADING
PORTABILITY FOR A LICENSES FOR
THE BARBARIGO SCIENCES FROM
OTHER STATES I WHEN THEY COME
TO CALIFORNIA. AND ISSUES- THIS
IS A TREMENDOUS TREMENDOUS
BENEFIT WILL BE A TREMENDOUS
BENEFIT TO THE STATE. AND A END
TO END TO LAW ACCESS TO THE
STATE AS WELL. BALD REGARDING-
SOME OF THE SUNSET AFTER 2% OF
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED. WE WILL- USUALLY.
JOHN AND- TENSION BLAMES AND AT
COM ON. L. WE DO HAVE BEEN TELL
US IS A PLAY- ESPECIALLY WITH
JOHN THE WHERE- YES VERY WELL.
IN IN. BODIES REACT DURING THE
MID OF A. R. Y. HAVE GROUND.
THIS GIVES ACTS TO P. IS VERY
OF. AND IS A STATE VERY CYNICAL
TO CRACK. RT THE BACKGROUND
PAPER APPRECIATE THEIR MUCH
DOING. WHAT TO SPEAK TO ISSUE
NUMBER ONE ON- ON THE PAGE. WE
GOT HEALTHY REPRESENT THE- IS.
SPEAK SPECIFIC TO THE- TOPIC IS
SUPPORTED WITH THE STAFF THE
AND ON THE BOARD- AS IN
SEGMENTS OF SHOULD. THE PLATE
CLOWN COUNSELOR MY- STRUGGLES
WITH HAVING TO BE MORE BECAUSE
EQUAL WHAT THE OTHER LICENSE-
IN THE THAT'S A BIT KIND OF A
BILL WHITE IT THAT'S THAT IS
REALLY. ARE TO MATTER. TO- YEAH.
BECAUSE THEY YEAH ISSUES OF
ISSUE CALL ABOUT THE- WHY DO
ONLY ALFIE C. C. ON THE BOARD-
BETTER A MATTER OF HISTORY WAS
THE PA COMES ALL OF SENATE BILL
TO MAKE THE- IN THOUSAND AND
WHEN DOLLARS CIRCLE WIDENS BILL
SB SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT AND I
CAME TO THE LEGISLATURE- I WILL
BE IN ALICE'S FOR THE COMMITTEE
FOR THAT. IT WAS A LICENSING
DEAL WHICH ESTABLISHED THAT THE
L. P. C. SEE. LICENSED IN
CALIFORNIA. THE BILL WOULD ADD
AS WE CAME THROUGH- IT CAME TO
THE CENTER AND WHAT ABOUT TO
HELP YOU SEE C. H. TO THE BOARD
AT THE TIME. ADD TO THE BOARD
OUT. THAT WAS AMENDED ON THE
FLOOR THE SECOND HOUSE- TO
REDUCE TO ONLY ONE OKAY SINCE.
WHAT WAS DONE AT THE ENERGY OF
THE SHORE AND- IT WAS. WITH
THANK. BUT NEVER STATE BANK
BOARDS. SO AS THIS ISSUE MOVES.
AND BACK IN THE LARGER.
ANDERSON'S AND THAT LIKE TO.
THAT BE I COME OUT OF THIS.
WILL BE TO IN HATEVER WAY THAT
WE- IN ORDER TO ASSURE IN THE-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS AIR- MODERATOR THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU BOOK
ONLINE NOW TO LINE EIGHTEEN ONE
EIGHT LINERS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JENNIFER ALLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
REPRESENTING THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND AND THAT HE'S BEEN
SOCIAL NETWORKING SECTION OF
THE BORDER YOU CAN GO ONLINE TO
ASPEN THAT. MOM MARCH THIRTIETH
AT THAT THE VIETNAM. I DON'T
FOUR TOMORROW NIGHT STEPHEN
REGISTRANT. IN ADDITION THE OF
THE- SHIP FACT UP AND RESPONSE
TEMA ISSUES BOUNCE THE HEALTH
AND- HERE ASIAN COUNTY NUMBERS.
PEDIATRIC DONE AN EXCELLENT JOB
AT EIGHTEEN ATMOS ANNOUNCING IN.
SAMPLE TO BE. REGULARLY THE
POWER WITH ME TIME INFORMATION
ON FACEBOOK FRIDAY WITH A NOW
QUESTION THAT ARE ANSWERED. I'M
IN THE BDS OF THE OUT TO
NUMEROUS PEOPLE GROUPS TO
ENSURE UNDER THE NEW STAFF WERE
ARE JOHN THE BACK. THEY
REGULATE I'M IN THE B. B. S.
ALL PUBLIC NEWS. NEWSLETTER AND
UPDATES- INFORMED. THIS GUY
DONNELLY BASIS- AND- WE REALLY
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE HARD
WORK OF OUR ELIEF IN ACCESS TO
THEM NOT THE COMPLEX ISSUES
THANK YOU. HUMUS SALLY-
MODERATOR THERE ANY FURTHER
CALLERS ON THE LINE. YOU KNOW
MR THERE NO FOR THE CALLERS ON
THE LINE. HI CAN I GIVE ALL THE
FINAL LAST CALL FOR ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY ON
THE REVIEW OF THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES TO. A CALL
IN THE NEXT FEW SECONDS SO WE
CAN MAKE SURE WE INCLUDE YOU IF
NOT WE'LL CLOSE THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY OPERATOR CAN MAKE
THAT AS A REMINDER THAT TIME.
THE BADGERS CARE THE REMINDER
IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE. THANK YOU THERE
ARE NO LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
MODERATOR AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HELP TODAY MUCH
APPRECIATED- WITH THAT WILL
THANK- MISS WONG IN MISSISSAUGA
GRIN THIS. IS HELMS. MR GAS-
THAT QUICK MCMANUS. AND ALL
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
THE BOARD OF THE HAVERHILL
SCIENCES FOR YOUR- TESTIMONY
AND RESPONSES TODAY WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU IN
THE COMING WEEKS. ON THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED- IN THE
BACKGROUND. PAPER SO I WANT TO
THANK AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR
AGENDA TODAY I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE. BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE FOR
PARTICIPATING IN THE HEARING
TODAY I. KNOW WE HAD THAT
FAMILY MEMBERS FONG IN BLOOM.
AND- EGGMAN DISSIPATING
REMOTELY- AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS STAYING IN CHAIR LOW
AND SENATOR PANTY- HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS AUS WONDERSTONE CENTER
ACTUAL LETTER WAS ABLE TO
MONITOR CALL HAD SOME TECHNICAL%
ISSUES AND WE WELCOME HIM TO
OUR DELIBERATIONS WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE ROBUST
DISCUSSIONS ON ALL THE ISSUES
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT TODAY SO
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF THE
PROCESS OF THE SUNSET REVIEW.
IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
OR THE ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY THE OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORDS. THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
I WITH THAT I WANT HAVE FINALLY
THANK OUR POLICY- STAFF FROM
BOTH HOUSES. AND CERTAINLY OUR
TECHNICAL STAFF HERE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS WHO PROVIDED
THE- ENVIRONMENT FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATION WE HAD
TODAY THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION. WE
DO- CONTINUE OUR HEARING
TOMORROW IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS UNDER CARILLO FOR
THREE ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHTS.
AND WITH THAT AT THE CONCLUSION
OF OUR AGENDA THIS OVERSIGHT
HEARING IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH.